sao ơ nhầm nhm nh to
nhớ cái này đều xin chào các bạn Đợi
mình tí Đợi mình
tí mình đang chỉnh lại cái độ phân giải
của cái mà này
đ này bé quá chả nhìn th cái gì cả bé
Ơ nhớ bình thường là cái nhá Cái này của
tôi vừa với cả cái n màn này mà nhỉ Sa
hôm nay trông kiểu tôi cứ cảm thấy là
cái này nó bé hơn ấy nhỉ chỉ là một góc
của màn ấy
đ thế nhở Anh em nào biết chỉnh cái nào
không ạ đành
hặc
đợi tí tôi chừng lại l à Dùng mic này
Alo ạ Đỡ chưa đợi Đợi tí Đợi tí tôi phải
chỉnh ngại vài cái đấy Ờ input này Ui bé
quá Alo ạ Thế đủ to chưa
ạ to quá Chưa ạ Cái này cảnh báo đỏ lòm
đấy thế th Chắc là bây giờ đỡ hơn rồi
đúng
á Cái này bởi vì tôi đang để độ mic của
mic nó hơi nhạy để mà đang Phả hẳn quạt
vào mấy cái quạt đây r Tôi đang không mở
điều hòa mấy không ạ Nên là khí hậu ở
miền Bắc là phải chơi mấy cái quạt bây
giờ
Ừ Mấy ông nghe bảo tôi dè thì tôi chỉnh
lại một tí nhá Đỡ chưa Đỡ chưa thông cảm
lần đầu như kiểu lần đầu livestream
ấy cái bên này vừa mà tại sao cái dưới
này nó cứ kểu kiểu bị che mất một khoảng
nhỉ do độ phân giải à đợi tô tí giải có
ảnh hưởng gì không
đã nhìn nó rõ đã cận rồi Không không
không nhìn thấy cái chữ gì
ạ
Ờ input này chọn này tter nó cũng chỉ có
mỗi chế độ này
tôi à Rồi rồi rồi rồi chọn nhầm bên lỗi
tôi lỗi tôi lỗi tôi lỗi tôi
đây Ô
ok
rồi chào các bạn hôm nay sẽ một buổi
livestream tâm sự thực ra Ờ Lúc đầu Lúc
đầu này tôi sẽ đầu video này tôi nghĩ là
tôi
sẽ chữa cái cv cho vài Hai bạn có hai
bạn đang CV nhờ tôi chữa ở trên server
discord nên là tôi sẽ chữa các bạn trước
đã nói chung là sau đó thì mình sẽ làm
việc riêng sau tức là mình sẽ tâm sự
thực sự sẽ có nhiều cái kiểu để tôi tôi
muốn chia sẻ với mọi người
thì thực ra là định hướng lúc đầu của
tôi tôi nói thì đó là không không muốn
kênh dạng kiểu có mặt tôi cho lắm bởi vì
lúc đầu là mang thi nướng dạy học nên
chắc chắn là lúc dạy học thì các bạn
không cần biết mặt tôi để làm gì đúng
không ạ Các bạn chỉ cần tập trung vào
code không phải mặt tôi không phải cái
biểu cảm của tôi Vân Vân thôi không phải
con người Ừ không phải người biểu
cảm Tôi không khẳng định mình một người
biểu cảm nhiều biểu cảm lắm chắc là có
thể tự nhận mặt mình trông tấu hải giải
trí thì có nhưng chắc chắn là lúc đấy
các bạn không tập trung ngồi cốt được
nên là nó không cần có mặt tôi làm gì cả
Còn bây giờ thì
tôi định hướng của tôi thì kênh bản chất
kênh sẽ là Block à Tức cả mang Thiên
hướng là tôi sẽ chia sẻ góc nhìn và rất
nhiều thứ hơn và cái việc là là không có
mặt mình có người đánh giá với tôi đó là
m người nhận xét là kiểu nó trông nó
không gần gũi nó không thật Nên thôi Tôi
để mặt tôi đây cho cứ mỗi lần buổi hôm
nào tâm sự thì sẽ kiểu dạng là hi thị
mặt các thứ các thứ Ờ có nay sẽ mặc á vơ
Nếu mớ không thấy á
vơ không quả cáo gì đâu Ờ hôm n mới cắt
tóc cạo dâu có thứ thứ Nói chung là
trông cần s sủa tí Trước khi lên màn
hình đấy ấn tượng đầu nên là ấn tượng
tốt đúng không ạ đấy chứ ngay vừa chiều
nay thì tóc kiểu Hai tháng chưa cắt xong
ngồi kiểu râu ria các thứ các thứ đấy
Nói chung là sáng nay như kiểu người
rừng nhưng mà bây giờ Thôi thì lên lên
sóng Cần chỉn chu bảnh bảnh bao gọn gàng
tí
tôi tạm Tắt cái màn hình này một tí để
tôi thc ra Tôi đã phải chuẩn bị trước n
hôm nay ngủ quên hôm nay hơi vỡ kế hoạch
hơi nhiều thứ Ờ tôi xem tạo tắt màn hình
một tí để mà tôi mở CV của hai bạn kia
để tôi chỉnh sửa lại tôi không Chưa chưa
mở lên để xem thử Để có gì tôi còn
à che bớt thông tin nhạy C các bạn đấy
một phần là thực ra chuẩn là thứ nhất là
không nên để l thông tin nhạy cảm của
kiểu các bạn Đấy là một đúng không ạ một
phần nữa đó là như nào nhỉ
Ừ tôi nhớ là thằng YouTube YouTube có
đánh gậy vài vài thằng có đánh gậy khi
mà các bạn Lỡ để thông lộ thông tin
không biết là thông tin của mình hay
thông tin của người khác nhưng đại khái
là hồi trước tôi nhớ Tôi có bị đánh gậy
mùm không phải đánh gậy như đại khái bị
xóa một cái video đấy có liên quan đế
việc để lỗi thông tin cho dù mình không
nhớ được cái video video nó nó xóa nó
không ừ xóa nó cũng có nói video nào đó
nhưng mà không nói lý do cụ thể không
nói trích dẫn tại cụ thể dây nào Vân Vân
không
review
thoại ở đây này cũng khá là nhận
nhau à power by cá qu zoom
à form giống nhau nhưng mà có vẻ tạo ở
nơi khác
nhau trông chuyên nghiệp á không Tôi
trông đừng nói tôi trông chuyên nghiệp
trông tôi cật nhà giải
trí
ờ xem nào
đã mấy bạn này
giờ Bây giờ mình tôi sẽ phải chụp ảnh
lại nhỉ chụp ảnh lại sau đó
pdf to jbg đi đấy à nh luôn á có cả xel
à đỉnh vậy tôi sẽ convert kề file pdf
này ra An xong rồi
che các bạn có gì hôm nay là buổi tâm sự
nên các bạn có gì cứ hỏi nhá rồi tôi sẽ
trả lời dần đúng không ạ
thử thứ nữa các bạn có thể
đình nhắn trong link này thì nó sẽ tự
động cập nhật
trợ thì hỗ trợ tôi trả lời luôn càng tốt
Xin cảm
lộ tên không nhỉ Thôi cứ để tạm Tên thì
chắc là không nhạy cảm lắm thôi sẽ che
cái khác thôi
Ờ Bây giờ dùng cái gì để sửa Nhanh nhở
dùng pên đi tên sửa nhanh
theo là cái bên bạn này ô bạn ấy cũng để
dùng cái trang I love pdf này nó cũng
hay hay ch hay hay
COD từ An không ạ Em đi Enter mà đọc
code khói hiểu quá chỉ có thể là chỉ có
thể em vào một công ty setup khi mà chưa
có sẵn code thì mai em không ngợp thôi
chứ bản chất là đúng Em đọc code của
người đi
trước thì em kiểu gì cũng sẽ ngợp Nói
chung là cái đấy Đều chắc chắn khó mà
tránh đặc biệt là có một vài công ty
không đủ chuyên nghiệp không đủ to nên
là em sẽ
không ạ có bị giật tiếng Không ạ Nói
chung là công ty không đủ to để mà kiểu
tách ra những cái cái module nhỏ nên là
mặc định khi vào là bạn vào dự án cái
project lớn luôn cái module lớn luôn nên
các bạn sẽ kiểu sẽ bị ngợp là đều chắc
chắn Ừ n là tôi
kiểu Tôi nghĩ là kiểu
mình kiểu điều đấy điều khó mà tránh
khỏi
lắm cái việc Tôi nghĩ là kiểu gì cũng sẽ
bị quá tải ngợp ấy chắc chắn là mình
phải quen dần với nó mình kiểu thôi chấp
nhận là ai cũng sẽ thế Quan trọng là ai
cũng sẽ thế Giả sử là có mỗi mình Mình
ngược thì mình còn quan ngại ai cũng sẽ
Thế thì chắc là thôi mình coi đấy cứ cho
ở đấy uây Vừa rồi tôi bị offline
à Uầy Vừa rồi mất mạng đúng
chắc không bị đánh gậy gì gì
Mình xin phép chia sẻ review CV của hai
bạn Các bạn có gì Các bạn à vẫn có thể
nhắn trên server discord của của mình
hoặc
là hoặc là kiểu à Nhắn team trực tiếp
mình Tùy mình sẽ hỗ trợ các bạn về rất
nhiều cái có thể tâm sự tuổi hồng có thể
là
ờ hỗ trợ về trong trong ngành hoặc là
đấy hỗ trợ civ các thứ không cần phải
đúng ngành cũng được Mình rất là thoải
mái đời tiên thì đây CV một bạn Ờ để
mình cái CV này thì thường là chắc là
nhắn trực tiếp á nên qua discord bởi vì
Facebook tôi cần bị khóa lần thứ hai rồi
tạo clon rồi cũng bị khóa hơi khó chịu
nên tốt nhất là tôi thấy là discord thì
chắc chắn là khó khóa này hoặc là tươ
nhiên tôi cũng chưa đủ thân với mấy ông
để mà có thể công khai số điện thoại cho
dù mấy ông có thể ngồi tra lại có thể ra
số điện thoại T đấy tôi cũng từng bị lộ
mấy lần và tôi cũng chấp nhận đó số điện
thoại chuẩn là số điện thoại đấy cũng là
số điện thoại có thể công khai được
cả anh không để ảnh đại diện nhưng mà À
đâu Không không không phải nhầm Bình
phạm cơ Bình Nguyễn thì chắc là cái ông
Ừ tôi tôi nhớ ông ông nào rồi tôi tưởng
Ông anh Bình lên trêu tôi hỏi về design
cũng không rõ xếp tôi thì khoe là đợt
dịch ấy xếp a sế đầu tư cho mỗi anh em
một con ghế Công Thái Học này ship đến
tận nhà không biết nó mua như th nào
Hình như là hình như là
ờ sếp bảo là mua từ bên Mỹ Hình như thế
hình như thế à thôi quay quay tr lại chủ
đề này đó là
đây Cái này chắc là bạn ấy tự dùng word
hay cái gì đó đ chia thì tôi thấy là
hoặc là cái mẫu này ở đâu đấy Nói chung
là tôi ừ có khi là mẫu ấy trông vẻ căn L
cho là mẫu thì tôi sẽ đánh giá là thứ
nhất là tiếng Anh thì cũng được ok nhưng
mà chẳng biết mẫu hay không tự nhiên cái
đoạn này nó lại tông khác nhỉ tông đoạn
này à Rồi Rồi background À đây đây đây
từ tiêu đề ok ok
thứ nhất là nếu bạn để được tiếng Anh
như thế này là rất tốt mình nhưng mà nên
tạo hai bản một bản tiếng Anh một bản
tiếng Việt tiếng Anh thì tôi nhớ là cái
mấy bạn bản tiếng Anh ấ thường là mọi
người sẽ không viết có dấu bao gồm cả
tên mình đấy còn bản tiếng Việt thì
thoải mái đúng không ạ
Đấy Tôi góp ý từng cái này nên là anh em
nhớ được cái gì thì nhớ nhá Tôi ngại th
nốt lại lắm
Ờ ngại ghi ché lại các th thử đấy tiếp
theo là bạn ấy để email cá nhân tô thấy
là nó tên cá nhân kết H với những ngày
tháng năm sinh hay gì gì đó thường là
các bạn không nên để email cá nhân cho
công việc n tạo một cái email khác ví dụ
Giả sử Tôi có một email riêng cho công
việc và một email cá nhân
khác nên là kiểu nên tạo một cái email
riêng hạn chế kiểu tôi lại nhớ cái email
của anh
jvm khi anh yêu chịu trái tin đan vỡ acc
BCS chok chẳng hạn đấy m cái mấy cái
email kiểu thời trẻ châu chá u các thứ
thứ thế không càng không nên để đấy nên
tạo một email riêng công việc đấy thứ
hai là bạn các bạn để số điện thoại
thường là tôi có nghe nhiều người bảo là
để số điện thoại nó không sao Thực ra
tôi lại cảm thấy có sao vì các bạn rất
hạn chế để lộ thông tin cá nhân của mình
hãy nên nhớ là im cái CV các bạn nó sẽ
qua tay rất rất nhiều người nên là khi
mà các bạn để lộ quá nhiều thông tin
thậm chí là cả địa Trì có người để số
nhà có người để tận số phòng luôn đấy
kểu tầng mấy tầng mấy cà không nên không
ai kiểu đến tận nơi cho các bạn để làm
gì cả đúng không ạ cào không nên để lộ
quá nhiều thông tin số điện thoại cũng
thế trừ khi đây cũng là một số điện
thoại riêng cho công việc thì ok còn để
còn không thì không nên để lộ được thông
tin bởi vì sao về một nơi chuyên nghiệp
thì sẽ liên hệ bạn qu email chứ không
phải gọi điện đúng không ạ Đấy đấy cái
link kiểu như này là một trong link Mà
tôi cũng không biết nho nhưng mà hơi khó
bây giờ gửi cho người ta Cái này người
ta không biết bấm vàoo kiểu gì đúng
không ạ Nên là các bạn nên tìm cách thế
nào Một là link rút gọn gì gì đó Nói
chung là một cái tiên miền gì gì đó Vân
Vân tại khái là cái gì đó Trông có thể
tương tác hay làm gì đó được nhanh Người
ta Người ta không có tận nơi như này để
mà vào link của mình còn nếu không thì
nên để có bạn T tí nữa bạn ấy để cái l
lendin chẳng biết phát âm như nào nữa t
link link in à đấy à Linkin à Ừ Để qu
cũng được đấy nghĩa là ý tôi Ấy là làm
sao cho mà tiện nhất cho cái người kia
người ta người ta cũng có thể tò mò về
trang web của các bạn hay sản phẩm các
bạn làm chứ tự nhiên Kiểu nhìn thấy kiểu
người ta ngại try cập vào đúng không và
người ta còn đánh giá thấp nữa Đó là
kiểu em làm cho người ta cảm thấy bất
tiện đấy Kiểu thế người ta sẽ ngại đúng
không Đương nhiên là nếu mà bạn gửi file
bdf cho người khác người ta thể bấm được
vào link có không phố nhận điều đấy
nhưng mà các bạn có thể in ra cả bản
cứng nữa mà đúng không y là bản cứng để
mà đưa cho người ta mà đúng
không đúng nếu mà file pdf này tôi vừa
rồi tôi có thể bấm được vào link nói chỗ
không sao Nói chung là tôi đang nói là
kiểu
tiện vân vân được bao nhiêu tiện bao
nhiêu được thì càng tốt đấy đấy theo góp
nhìn tôi nhá nghĩa là tôi khi mà tôi
review cái CV thì tôi vẫn đang chia sẻ
theo góc nhìn cá nhân khá là nhiều chứ
không phải là
cái tiêu chuẩn nào cả mình không có tiêu
chuẩn nào ở đây cả đợi tôi một tí Đợi
tôi một tí
là Nói chung là nếu mà Bạn ổn tiếng Anh
hoặc là bây giờ có ai hỗ trợ rồi chắc
cũng đỡ nhưng mà cũng không nên chém gió
gọi là thể hiện mình biết tiếng Anh mà
cho khi
a cho cho khi bạn tự tin tiếng Anh thật
chứ bạn để một cái CV toàn tiếng Anh như
này thự ra trông rất là ngầu trong rất
là ấn tượng như hơn tôi rồi chắc chắn vì
tôi không có Cv bằng tiếng Anh đấy Nhưng
mà nếu mà các bạn để được các th thứ thì
tôi nghĩ là bạn phải ổn tiếng Anh ở cũng
gọi là chá biết đánh giá thế nào Ổn
không thể nói là kiểu Anh phải trên bao
nhiêu bao nhiêu được vì tính ra tôi còn
chưa làm mael hay t nhưng mà bạn phải tự
tin về nó đã đúng không Thì bạn để tv
tiếng Anh nhưng mà nếu mà để được thì
đương nhiên là vẫn đánh giá cao đúng
không ạ Đấy objective objective là kiểu
mục tiêu à đúng không là sinh viên năm
cuối th thứ chưa có nhiều kinh nghiệm
kiểu làm con người kiểu nhiệt tình à
passional là kiểu đam mê nhiệt huyết À
đấy ren expiring ch kìa kiểu đam mê về
mạng fen đúng không
À looking for a Challenge Ô bây giờ tự
nhiên tôi phải đọc bằng tiếng Anh ạ mọi
người cứ bỏ qua về tiếng Anh tôi nhá
challeng challenging intership of
opportunity to g hand on ây Dùng mấy từ
đ b lớn thật không biết có xống chat gì
thì cần Thiệp đấy không kiểu đại khái nà
kiểu
tìm cơ hội Thực tập thử thách thực tập
nhưng mà thử thách để mà thêm trải
nghiệm
à Không biết Hon là gì luôn V từ này
mới experi in and Ui and
fin Cái này có khi không phải chity ch
nó không tôi không Nghĩa là nó để lặp từ
như
này để lặp từ từ như này và cái đoạn này
nó ux Ui thì tôi nghĩa là nó như fance
rồi Đ chắc là tôi nghĩ là lặm sửa lại
một tí bằng chity chắc đỡ hơn tôi thường
ha dùng chity để kiểu Tôi bảo là improve
My grammar rồi copy cả một đoạn dài xống
dưới để nó sửa lại thậm chí là kiểu
không tôi nói cái đoạn đấy bằng nửa anh
nửa Việt luôn nhưng mà vẫn bảo nó dịch
ra tiếng Anh và sửa lại ngữ pháp các thứ
thứ cho nó mượt chẳng hạn và cũng đương
nhiên nên nói rõ cụ thể là trong hn
trong ngữ cảnh nào Ví dụ Giả sử là viết
email là một kiểu viết CV là một kiểu
viết để mà nhắn tin hội thoại là một
kiểu hội thoại sẽ ngắn gọn xú tích email
nên trình bày rõ ràng đầy đủ ý con CV
thì cũng nên ngắn gọn nhưng mà nó là
theo kiểu đấy mấy từ dat b lớn đấy Vân
Vân đúng không ạ I'm Eagle to apply
the từ này cá anh qu quen này thôi bỏ
qua lại khá kiểu
đúng
không đóng góp vào kể dự án có ý nghĩa
và cải thiện kỹ năng
đấy Uầy đúng kiểu i đi Kết xong
rồi
expiring to learning and growing in any
field making
a
positive impact on organization decision
making
nhưng
mà chỉ muốn bạn này đang chỉ dừng lại
mỗi fanel thì tôi thấy cá nhân tôi thì
tôi nghĩ là đương nhiên bạn nếu mà bạn
chuyên fan hay kiểu là chuyên về design
nữa cơ thì còn tốt à đây đây đây cũng có
kiểu mấy cái tool về design nhưng mà cá
nhân tôi là nếu mà Nếu có thể thì full
stack thì sẽ có thể cho mình thêm nhiều
lựa chọn ho chuyên về design thôi cũng
được Nói chung là bây giờ mình cũng đang
năm cuối mình mình xem cái nà phù hợp
đúng không
ng dịch lại các th các thứ
này Ừ cái này có con số này rất là hay
thường các bạn nên có một con số cụ thể
như này rất là hay
tính ra hơi ít bạn nên viết thêm về việc
là những cái dự án bạn đã từng làm nữa
dự án kiểu pet Project nữa có thêm một
cái mục Project ở đây nữa những cái cái
thứ để khoe hoặ đương nhiên là cái này
cũng có thể một à Không cái này CV bạn
đấy đúng không pf Chắc là civ bạn đấy
chắc là trong này sẽ có thể nói chi tiết
hơn tôi chưa vào link này tôi chưa rõ
nhưng mà CV của bạn đấy còn trống khoảng
này mà nếu mà bạn nà qua được những cái
pet Project những cái project kiểu bạn
đã từng làm thì nó sơ qua được thì tốt
nhưng cá nhân tôi Tôi đánh giá cao cái
đoạn kinh nghiệm này trông về ổn t này B
cấp các thứ thứ trong ngồn này kỹ năng
này đấy Thì bởi vì bởi vì các bạn có ít
kinh nghiệm và không có Project để khoe
mấy nên là bạn mới phải ngồi nói thêm về
kỹ năng Chứ thực tế thực đấy Tôi muốn
đấy là vẫn tôi bảo nói th mọi thử trên
góp định nhìn của tôi nhá Tôi cũng chưa
phải là nhà Tuyển dụng tôi cũng
chưa Chưa đi tuyển dụng ai giờ thực ra
có trực tiếp phỏng vấn thôi nhưng mà
chưa Tuyển dụng ai mấy nế là rất khó để
mà kiểu nói một cách chính xác được
nhưng mà tôi biết được là ví dụ tôi đang
áp dụng ấy thì là phần Kỹ
năng phần Kỹ năng này ờ
năng kỹ năng Sở thích là những thứ mình
không cần đề cập vì rõ ràng là mình Thứ
nhất là về kỹ năng đã mình hoàn toàn có
thể nói qua được ở phần kinh nghiệm và
Project mình rồi còn sở thích thì thường
là tôi nghĩ không nên ghi vào trừ khi là
các bạn
là một là có sở thích liên quan đến t
biểu đình hai sở thích liên quan đến
kiểu Ờ th hiện mình dụ ví dụ vài sử
thích tôi nghĩ là nên ghi vào được này
một Ờ thích đọc sách Ừ nghĩa thể hiện
một người thích nghiên cứu hai
là thích chơi game ví dụ ví dụ cũng phải
ví dụ một tí chơi game phải tùy từng
game ví dụ ví dụ Giả sử là biết được
công ty đấy cũng anh em đ biệ là sếp
chẳng hạn cũng kiểu tầm tuổi tầm tầm
tuổi đấy hoặc tầm tuổi hơn một tí đấy
không thích đánh đi chế chẳng hạn đấy
thích chơi game game m3 với game chính
vật game Đi Chế biết đâu lại Đấy là một
cái cửa gì đó sáng hơn cho mình hoặc là
thậm chí là thích đá bóng bởi gì rất
nhiều công ty đấy rất nhiều công ty
thích hoạt động về đá bóng thể thao gì
gì đó Đấy ghi sơ thích đấy vào cũng được
Và thậm chí là bạn hướng đến cái công ty
có cùng đam mê như thế với mình cũng
càng tốt đấy nhưng mà còn sở thích theo
kiểu hôm trước tôi xem có phải bạn ghi
sở thích kiểu thích xem phim thích đi
ngủ cái đấy không bao giờ nên ghi vào CV
người ta không cần biết những điều đấy
của bạn hãy nên nhớ CV nó không phải là
là nơi để các bạn đă để tìm việc chứ
không phải là tìm bạn đời tìm nửa kia
hay là tìm một người thấu hiểu mình để
mà kiểu ghhi ghi mấy cái kiểu sở thích
không liên quan linh tinh vàở trong đấy
đấy thích uống trà sữa Chẳng hạn chẳng
chẳng cần Trừ khi bạn biết sếp của bạn
có sở thích kiểu kiểu như thế và muốn
chia sẻ cùng thôi tôi cũng không nghĩ là
kiểu mấy cái đấy nên ghi vào đúng không
ạ đấy Nên là sở thích Nếu có thể không
biết cái gì bỏ qua thể trống kỹ nặng thế
Nói chung là tôi từng nghe mày anh HR
tuyển dụng
à chia sẻ rồi đó là thức các bạn thấy
hiển nhiên mà một ngày ra phải duyệt bao
nhiêu cái CV đấy nên thành ra là anh ấy
từng chia sẻ là anh ấy từng m phút có
thể duyệt qua đợn hai đến ba cái CV thì
chắc chắn là người ta sẽ Lướt rất là
nhanh người ta không đọc về cái mô tả
nhiều đâu người ta đọc về thứ nhất là về
kinh nghiệm này Thứ hai là về dự án đã
từng làm này Thứ ba là về đẳng cấp này
những cái kỹ năng hay là những Ừ đúng
rồi Cái đọc cá chính chỉ nữa những cái
cùng lắm là thêm một vài cái hoạt động
khác nghĩa là hoạt động có thể tình
nguyện hay hoạt động vân vân vân gì đấy
hoạt động tham gia những cái cuộc thi
lớn vân vân gì đó nữa đó một điểm
cộng trừ khi người ta ấn tượng lắm người
ta mới bắt đầu đọc sang mấy cái mảng
khác của các bạn khi rõ ràng là phần Kỹ
năng phần vân vân thì nó không nên là
đánh giá quan trọng mình nên lược nó đi
CV mình trông dài quá người ta cũng cũng
đọc lướt thôi mà không hẳn là người ta
ngại đọc nói rằng người ta có đọc hết
đâu mà dùng từ ngại đấy nên là mình nổi
bật được cái phần nào nổi bật giống như
tôi B vừa bảo cái đoạn này bạn đấy làm
mấy cái kiểu về phần kị về phần kinh
nghiệm bạn ấy ghi được rõ ràng ra là
mình đã làm gì và có thêm vài con số ở
đấy nghĩa là trước đấy như nào sau đấy
Kiểu cải thiện vân vân bao nhiêu phần
trăm hay là kiểu ví dụ Giả sử là tăng
danh số danh vân vân bao nhiêu nó cũng
là một cái rất là tích cực rất là bắn
mắt rất là đáng để khoe đ Bạn có thể ghi
vào
đấy Bạn có thể ghi là sau 2 tháng em đã
được làm nhân viên chính thức làm nhân
viên của thá nhân viên của năm hay gì gì
đó rất là một cái gì là tốt mình khoay
vào tiếp theo đó là có Sinh viên hỏi tôi
là CV có được phép chém gió không anh
có thì các bạn nên chếm gió ở mức tầm
bạn 80 ph có những cái gì không thể chém
được thứ nhất là về bằng cấp hay là về
chứng chỉ cá đấy chắc chắn không nên
chém chém là chết đấy đấy thứ hai các
bạn thể chém về những cái gì kỹ năng thì
bảo bỏ qua rồi thì mình sẽ chuyển qua
kiểu nói về kinh nghiệm hay là Ờ đừng có
chém về hoạt động Nói chung là chém chém
vừa vừa thôi không Phả chém những cái
thứ chưa từng tồn tại đúng không ạ bạn
kiểu ví dụ giả sử nó chỉ là một cái C
gió nhẹ thì bạn cốn bốc Nó lên kiểu Chém
gió nó lên thành kiểu cơn bão chẳng hạn
đấy Kiểu thế ng chị cũng phải có một cái
gì đó rồi bạn mới chém lên đấy thì là
tốt Thế mới gọi là chém gió nhá
Đấy mấy cái chứng chỉ này trông nhiều
phết này trông ấn tượng phết đấy Nói
chung là theo tôi dừng lại đây là tool
này chứng chỉ này đấy còn mấy cái này và
cái này tôi Nếu có thể thì mình bỏ qua
cũng được Nếu có thể tôi tôi bảo mọi thứ
vẫn đánh giá trên góp nhìn của tôi có
thể là nó sẽ không biết thế
nào Ok không biết bạn Kha thì có on
không
à Thì tôi góp ý là như thế chắc bạn kiểu
gì cũng xem được thôi Ờ thích bật
x đẹp trai à Vừa
kỹ năng mềm à kỹ năng mềm Ừ cái phần Kỹ
năng kia thì nếu ghi kỹ năng mềm được
thì
tốt nhưng mà tôi tôi thì bởi vì tôi là
góc nhìn dân công nghệ ấy Tứ cả tôi Tôi
cũng không biết đánh giá kỹ đằ mềm mình
nên đánh giả mình mới ghi gì vào nữa chứ
và phải định hướng mình là người như nào
nữa ví dụ Giả sử
là À đúng rồi đúng rồi bạn ấy thiếu mất
một cái quên mất các bạn thiếu cái ở
dưới này nhá đó các bạn phải nên ghi cái
tiêu đề Kiểu cái gọi là nó gọi là title
à Nó gọi là gì nhỉ Vị trí vị trí của bạn
Tứ cả bạn muốn ứng tuyển ở vị trí gì bạn
vẫn phải ghi vào đây Đấy ví dụ không
phải là không phải là hôm trước có sin
sinh viên tôi ghi nhầm là sinh viên năm
cuối đây đó bạn muốn ứng tuyển vào vị
trí gì ở công ty Ví dụ Giả sử Tôi muốn
ứng tuyển vào frer Finance chẳng ạn đấy
nên ghi vào đây các bạn ghi như th này
thì là một trong những cái cũng là khiế
cái đấy là chấm điểm khuyến khuyết lớn
bắt buộc phải có đấy nhá Đấy à R và cái
thứ hai nữa đó là nếu có thể các bạn vẫn
nên chọn cái template có anh nên thế và
ảnh nên đ nh là trông cũng thể hiện được
phần nào con người của bạn mà à Bạn muốn
là một con
người trông à muốn con người trong môi
trường làm việc như thế nào nữa ví D Giả
sử là bạn muốn trong môi trường chuyên
nghiệp thì bạn trông ảnh trông phải
chuyên nghiệp một tí trông phải lịch sự
đấy còn nếu mà bạn muốn vào môi trường
kiểu cũng kiểu bông đù một tí thì bạn sẽ
kiểu ảnh nó thoải mái hơn tí đừng có ảnh
trên ba bụng ba bụng là được đấy à ảnh
khá bảnh ở đây chắc là không được đâu
thì có kinh nghiệm làm thì có mớt đ em
cứ ghi các đầu việc em đang nói cái viết
cv đúng không em Ghi các đầu việc là
kiểu các tính năng lớn của em đã làm là
gì nó Nó đã giải quyết được những cái
vấn đề gì đấy Vân Vân ghi những cái từng
đầu mục ra thế là
là để lộ số điện thoại về email đấy bạn
này thì để để quả link link cầ này thì
thật ra em nên chỉnh lại để cái us Cái
này có thể trình thành username thì nó
ngắn gọn hơn em đang để mặc định nó
thành ra trong như này đấy cả hai bạn để
tiếng Anh cũng khá là ấn tượng tiếp đó
là bạn này để cụ thể như này khá là tốt
này vì nên có không hẳn là theo tôi ấ
chuẩn ấy thì thích thì có thể để cuận
quận Xong rồi đến thành phố các thứ thứ
như này thấy là được
đấy bạn này còn để dùng email của Email
của Trưng thì thực ra thế này là một cái
điểm cũng không tốt lắm Ờ vì đấy các bạn
nên có một email Dành Riêng công việc
không phải email cá nhân và đặc biệt
không phải email trường Email trường với
sau hết hạn thì thôi bạn không làm nữa h
như nào đấy không nên đấy Tuy là có thể
là bạn cố tình để như này để mà kiểu
người ta biết được luôn Bạn học trường
nào cũng là một cách cũng là một cách
Nhưng mà không phải cách hay thôi
đấy các bạn đều giới thiệu qua bạn sinh
viên các thử th cũng được đấy back end
engineering
Tôi
không gọi như này không hẳn là không
thích khen nhưng mà HM chị Kiểu tôi luôn
đánh giá mình tôi thích Được Khen cái
khác hơn ở khen b thì tôi không để ý
ngoại hình n lắm
Ờ cái này em thấy bị cái lỗi gì không ạ
nó xuống r đây bạn thấy không ạ Bởi vì
các bạn phải khi mà khi mà gõ văn bản
thế
cái justify nó sẽ căn đều ở căn đề bộ
cục hai bên ấy đừng có cái này bạn đang
để căn trá như thành bị như này cũng
phải sửa lại này HR liên hệ đúng phải để
email Chứ ý là không phải email cá nhân
hay Email của trường email công việc Có
chứ tạo một email riêng công việc có số
điện thoại thì chỉ có nơi thiếu chuyên
nghiệp mới kiểu liên hệ em qua số điện
thoại thôi hoặc người ta đang rất cần
người ta thông báo em em lừa chck mail
nên th họ m phải thông báo qua số điện
thoại hoặc họ muốn gọi để thông báo
trước hay vân vân cái gì đó nhưng mà
Đúng là vẫn nên tạo Mình chuyên nghiệp
hoặc là em có ý số điện thoại riêng cho
công việc còn không thì anh bảo ấy nó Nó
là một cái hơi tế nhị một tí khi em để
lội thông tin của mình ra ngoài còn nếu
mà việc em chấp nhận thì cái thậm chí
gọi nhở Uầy Anh ơi cả tháng em còn chưa
được ai gọi người nhắn tetin Cuối Cho Em
Chỉ Là Viettel để nó nhắn kiểu chương
trình khuyến mãi thì bây giờ có người
nào nhắn em hay gọi em thì em mừng lắm
đấy Kiểu thế rồi ok ông kiểu như thế thì
chấp nhận được nhưng ông hãy nên nhớ đó
là một khi ông từng bị lộ rồi thì về sau
về sau ông muốn muốn gỡ không gỡ được
không muốn bỏ gửi được thế về sau giả sử
ông cứ kiểu kiểu như tôi đi tôi hồi
trước tôi tôi không phản chủ quan đâu
nhưng mà tôi cũng kiểu cứ cứ công khai
Tôi cứ kệ để đấy bây giờ rất nhiều người
biết số điện thoại tôi Vừ tra tra à tra
qua link Facebook cũng ra được số điện
thoại vân vân này Đấy đương nhiên là may
giờ tôi chưa bị spam thôi Như về xong mà
tôi nổi nổi tí hơn tôi bị spam cái thế
nên là bây giờ cái số điện thoại này Tôi
đàng phải chấp nhận nó coi đây số điện
thoại mà ai cũng biết thể không bản số
điện thoại giác đây sẽ là số điện thoại
kiểu để gọi là xã rao đấy về sau tôi sẽ
không ở để Mở chuông cho cái số này tôi
gần đây tôi mới phải đi đăng ký số điện
thoại riêng cho cá nhân rồi Nghĩa Cái số
đấy tôi sẽ luôn Mở chuông điện thoại
nghĩa là bây giờ phải có hai điện thoại
đấy đấy một điện thoại cho công việc một
điện một điện thoại cho cá nhân đấy một
điện thoại luôn tắt chua một điện thoại
luôn mở chua
giọng cảm ơn Chắc là do cái mic nữa đấy
nhưng mà bạn nghe nói chuyện tôi nói
chuyện xong bạn sẽ thấy độ trẻ trâu của
tôi thôi chắc bạn sẽ rút
lại
ờ đây xong khóa trước anh Long rồi đang
đi làm có đấy Hôm nay sinh viên Tôi đi
làm đông à Mỗi tội sinh viên Tôi chưa
chắc là đang ngồi xem thôi sinh viên tôi
có thình Thoa ngồi xem nhưng
mà không phải không phải ngồi xem liên
tục vì vì còn không biết là tôi chẳng
nói với mấy bạn đấy là tôi sẽ livestream
về cái gì thì bạn ấy có thể nghĩ là tôi
đang livestream Dạ học thì chắc là bạn
ấy chưa cần V không cần học lại không
cần nhưng mà nhưng mà có tôi tự tin là
việc là là là sinh viên Tôi đi làm mọi
thứ thành công hơn của tôi có rồi mà mế
không bị mất ô
chữ
ở trên kênh của tôi đấy dạy từ cơ bản để
nâng cao cho
người không phải là người đúng chuyên
ngành có lắm tôi tự tin thế bởi vì tôi
quen dạy tránh annh nhiều hơn ngay bây
giờ tôi đang dạy Bách Khoa cũng là dạy
cho các bạn sinh viên học quản trị kinh
doanh với kế toán chẳng hiểu sao mình
toàn và mang tiếng là tôi rất thích đam
mê dạy đúng trên ngành để còn kiểu chia
sẻ được mình cái kiểu trong ngành mà
những cái nâng cao ấy toàn được dạy vào
một cái lớp kiểu các bạn nữ rồi Kiểu Học
kể toán th thứ tôi chỉ hay thích trêu
mấy cái bạn kế toán
à Tôi nhiêu tuổi rồi à Có vài câu rồi
Tôi nghĩ là nhờ các bạn trả lời hộ được
tôi hơi hơi ngại trả lời lại vài cái câu
thông cảm
với Dinh lưu đến sinh viên của mình đó
Nó là đạo đức ngh nghiệp nói chung là
kiểu
Ừ mình các bạn đúng là các bạn nữ rất dễ
có cảm tình với người mình ngưỡng mộ
người mình thần tượng tại biệ đương
nhiên thầy thầy giáo mọi thứ mà còn trẻ
tí nữa thì càng dễ bị thu hút các thứ
thứ nhưng mà mình nên giữ chuẩn mực hay
vân vân
phòng đâu anh dạy hẳn lập trình cơ bản
cho mấy bạn đấy thế
thoảng bị vấn đề à Không biết do phải do
gì không tự nhiên mạng mà thiếu ẩn định
nhỉ Các bạn thấy có vấn đề gì không ạ
thô thỉnh thoảng thấy bị disconnect này
Ất ổn Thật sự ấy đến giờ đó tiến mạng
Mới đóng
mà hiện anh là dòng vn ạ Hai anh cũng đi
làm ở công ty ạ trước mình có đi dạy
mình có đi học ở trường ca Đảng nghề
kiểu giống kiểu C Đảng nghề thôi và mình
có sau đó thì mình dạy luôn ở
đấy cắm Lan rồi Đấy cắm Lan rồi đấy cho
hiểu sao tự nhiên bị mất không hiểu
thì mình cần Đây mình có được 10i lại đi
dậy ở bên m Aptech à nên là bâ mình có
thể gọi là giảng viên có thể thế hoặc
người đi dạy thuê cũng được bởi vì chuẩn
là giảng viên là sẽ phải có trình độ
thạc sĩ hay gì gì đó mới được đường lớp
hay gì đó Mình chưa mộ chưa đạt được đế
cái trình độ đấy n mình có đi dạy cho
sinh viên thì
Ờ
MX5 Nói chung là cũng may cũng có bây
giờ cũng gọi là có tiền để đầu tư các
thứ thứ
rồi đầu tư là những cái thứ gọi là ồn ồn
thì tôi thích nghe mà kiểu dạng đầu tư
là mic này để mà ngồi tâm sự cho mấy ông
này C thử thử Ok quay lại CV tí
Ờ
thì An này nói vị trí Ôi kiêm hết luôn
à thế này nên cắn gọi là full
này chấp nhận phải link thôi hoặc là tên
của một cái gì đó để bấm vào cũng được à
để mà tra trên giub cũng được mô tả thớ
thứ mô tả này Thực ra Vẫn còn hơi sơ sài
một tí nhưng mà thôi chắc bạn muốn làm
theo kiểu liệt kê nên là thôi tôi cũng
không không nói cụ thể một cái gì cả
nhưng mà Bởi vì cái này khó chỉ nói qua
được cái bài toán chứ không nói được là
hướng giải quyết vân vân hay công nghệ
Bạn áp dụng hướng giải quyết là gì Công
nghệ áp dụng hay gì nó sẽ kiểu th ra
hình dung rõ được cái tư duy của bạn
ta sẽ không gõ được cái link này phải
bấm vào link Còn không thì nên biết cái
tên của cái project thì nó sẽ ổn hơn
ừ cái đoạn này nên viết hoa này ít nhất
viết hoa chữc cái đầu này
dụng Ấy chuẩn là phải từ mấy cái trong
này này người ta nhìn qua người ta biết
rồi không cần Liệt kê lại có thể có thể
liệt kê lại để cho người khác không th
không đọc cái này người ta đọc cái tổng
Tắt ở đây cũng được nhưng thực ra chuẩn
là là nếu mà trong này không thôi thì ổn
mà đúng không Bạn này có hai chang thì
vậ đây nữa
thông tin thông tin khác thông tin thêm
à Nó phải a diff
tôi à Không tôi nghĩa do cái đoạn này
sai nhầm đấy for langage langage th chữ
s th chỉ có một
không ấn tượng tốt lắm th ạ Không sao
không không không hẳn là không sao không
sao trên hai trang thì mới đáo quan ngại
thì nó giống cái khác
hơn
được cái pro bỏ được cái program
language đây Cái này thiếu chữ s cơ ừ
đấy nhá bạn ấy tự viết bạn tự viết mấy
cái tiêu đề này nên là có thể sai thì
không sao Ờ thì
bỏ cái này thì cho bạn ấy thêm được mấy
cái này vào hoặ chến giản là theo tôi ấy
thêm mỗi cái này này tôi X này nó một
cái chứng chỉ gì đó
thì ổn hơn đấy theo tôi như thế Ok tạm
mà chữa như thế
ạ quay
lại quay lại mặt mình thạ chẳng có gì để
khoe ở đây cả nhưng mà thôi Hôm nay là
một buổi tấm sự mà đúng không ạ Mình sẽ
ngồi
mình sẽ hôm nay sẽ tâm sự vài
cái các thứ thử đúng
nhắn tin trong Mình chưa mình thì thự ra
là mình chỉ nhớ hơi kém về tên mình cũng
lắm là nhớ được ảnh đại diện nên hy vọng
các
bạn C định ảnh à an như nào đây thể về
sau mình sẽ nhận dại bây giờ kiểu nói
mình không nhớ được lắm có bạn kaven kia
thì ảnh đại diện cho qu Queen Tôi nhớ
Ờ tôi
97 Thực ra theo mô tả của kênh tôi là
tôi 96 vì tôi xin tập M tôi sẽ tự nhận
tôi là ông em trên 6 BCH hoa nhưng phiên
bản lỗi lỗi tí phiên bản không xịn được
như
ạ tôi không Tôi không thể ủng hộ các bạn
dùng grack được nhưng mà chắc chắn
là nó là một con số lớn và một con số
gọi là nhỉ Thế là đấy là cái bài toán mà
thường anh nói đi nói lại là kiểu có dù
cck hay không nó bài toàn luô thùa thì à
có khuyên là Nếu có thể thì bạn
à khi bạn đã kiếm được thu nhập mọi thứ
thì bạn vẫn nên ủng hộ tác giả Còn trước
mắt thì để phục vụ cho việc học tập hay
vân vân vân thì à có rất nhiều cách mà
không hẳn crack nhưng đại khái là có thể
dùng Active py ở hay gì gì đó Nói chung
là trên mạng Tôi thấy cũng có nhiều
nhưng mà đương nhiên là phải tìm nguồn
uy tín nhá Không thì thường người ta bảo
không ai cho ai miễn phí cái gì trừ tôi
thể cho các bạn nhiều cái miễn phí này
đấy Nhưng mà thực sự không phải ai như
thế n thành ra là
Ờ nó sẽ thường dính có thể bị dính virus
hay gì gì đó đấy n nên cẩn
thận
em ba trường 25
à Sáng đi làm tránh ngành Tối về học
code liệu có cơ hội không anh
ờ th ra Chính em cũng trả lời được câu
đấy rồi nghĩa là em đang muốn học code
Em đang cảm thấy là làm tránh ảnh nó nó
không có thể không phù hợp không thoải
mái Nên em thành ra em muốn quay lại
việc học cố và cái đấy Em là người cảm
thấy phù hợp hay không chứ không phải
là cơ hội thì ở ngoài kia luôn có nhưng
mà rất nhiều người đang đang gọi là họ
đang chạy theo chạy theo vì họ nghĩ
là mọi người chạy thì mình chạy thế thôi
chứ thực ra họ còn chưa B biết được là
cái nào mới phù hợp với mình Nếu giả sử
em cảm thấy thực sự nó phù hợp với mình
thì mình hãy cố chứng minh điều đấy là
mình theo đuổi không phản theo đuổi đến
cùng đôi khi là mình phải biết được giới
hạn mình nên dừng lại mức độ nào Nhưng
quan trọng là theo anh thì à em A tuổi
trẻ thì mình chưa nên gò bó bản thân
giới hạn bạn thân cái gì cả Mình cứ phải
theo thực sự phải chứng minh được là
mình theo được đến nơi đến chốn một cái
gì đó
đã mình phải thực xứ mình phải đấu tranh
quyết liệt vì nó đã chứ mình bỏ cuộc
giữa chừng Thi kể gọ là hồi trước có cái
câu là bỏ cuộc là thói
quen thói quen xấu à hay gì đó thói quen
khó bỏ ng gì gì ng đại khái là rất nhiều
người đã chọn bỏ cuộc sớm thừ thế không
các bạn là cứ cắm đầu vào theo ngày công
nghệp tin đi nó tươi sáng nó kiểu trển
vọng lắm nó nghe thấy đa cấp quá nhưng
mà các bạn thứ nhất là các bạn kể cả
trái ngày đúng ngy thì các bạn cảm thấy
là muốn thử học muốn thử thì đừng coi Nó
là một cái gì đó kiểu vui thử chỉ trong
1 ha tháng có thử thử không bạn thực sự
là bạn à gọi là bạn gọi như hồi trước
tôi thường ha Nói mấy ông đó là phải học
phải thử trải nghiệm nó ít nhất 1000
nhìn giờ thì bạn mới cũng tương đối hiểu
qua cơ bản mọi thứ về nó sau đó thì bạn
mới đánh giá
tiếp lúc đấy tự bạn cảm thấy là bạn
nà tự bạn cảm thấy phù hợp hay không
Không phải tôi nói hay là người khác nói
tự Bạn sẽ cảm thấy
thế à Chịu không nhớ đâu Nếu anh là nhà
thể dụng thì anh yêu cầu Face sơ những
gì thứ gì
ạ nhà Tuyền dụng chung nhá Không nói về
trình độ nhá thì chắc chắn là bây giờ
các bạn đều đang thiếu rất là lớn thứ mà
các bạn thiếu đặc biệt so với người thế
hệ trước không phải thế hệ trước nó kiểu
hơi bị xa quá nghe kiểu Tôi cảm thấy
Nhiều lúc tôi cảm thấy bị thượng đẳng à
bị già hơn các thứ thứ tôi cũng là kenz
mà Nhưng mà thực sự mà nói thì đúng là
tôi thường ha được thấy thấy chung mọi
người có đánh giá bây giờ Đó là kiểu bây
giờ là mình lứa trẻ mới này đặc biểu mờ
ra trường này chẳng hay bị nhạy cảm quá
thường dễ cục ngã dễ bỏ cuộc quá Cần
phải lúc nào cần healing cần lúc nào
phải chữa lành hay vân vân đấy
à không chịu được áp lực lớn không chịu
được các thứ thứ thì mình à à
giữ được cái thái độ làm việc hay mọi
thứ chuyên nghiệp được thì tốt đấy mình
nên gọi nh mình
thứ
kiểu kiểu dạng đam mê tuổi trẻ mình các
thứ thứ tuổi trẻ mình có nhiệt huyết mà
mình thể hiện được nó ra thì tốt đấy
chạy theo một công việc nào đó thứ nhất
là bởi vì cơ hội cao thứ hai là lương
cao Nếu bạn chạy theo mấy cái kiểu như
thế thì đâu phải là bạn thực sự thích
cái ngành đấy vì những cái đặc thủ ngành
ấy đâu bạn nó chạy theo một cái thứ khác
một cái viển vông một cái gì gì đó Thế
giả sử về sao không hẳn là lương nó
không còn cao nữ đâu mà lương nói thẳng
là nó vẫn luôn cao nó vẫn sẽ mãi cao như
chỉ ở vị trí nào thôi Thứ hai là cơ hội
cũng thế cơ hội nó vẫn là chia đều tất
cả mà bây giờ các bạn thấy cơ hội tuyển
Diệm nhiều đồng nghĩa là sai Hải cũng
nhiều chứ Đấy là một thứ hai đó là cơ
hội nhiều nhưng mà số lượng người học
cũng đông cái chia đấy tỷ lệ nó còn thấp
hơn cả ngành khác ví dụ thế Tôi không
biết được bây giờ tỉ lệ đang bao nhiêu
để tôi tô thể khẳng định ngành ngành nào
lớn hơn ngành nào nhưng mà chạy theo
những cái tiêu chí như thế là một trong
những cái sai lầm Đầu Tiên nã tôi theo
ngành này không phải bởi vì nó có thu
nhập hay mọi thứ đâu tôi theo ngành này
bởi vì tôi cảm thấy tôi hợp ngành này
Tôi cảm thấy tôi không thể hợp ngành nà
khác hơn tôi thử làm công việc khác rồi
không thể làm được đấy nế là tôi mới mới
theo ngành này Nó là một cái đó riêng
cái lựa chọn của tôi đã thế khác V đa số
rồi Nhiều người là nhiều người là vì đ
tiên hay vân vân vân nên người ta bỏ
cuộc cũng cũng nhanh Bởi vì người ta cảm
thấy không được như kỳ vọng người ta bỏ
cuộc luôn con tôi làm ngành này bởi vì
tôi được ngồi máy tính cả ngày này th
Tôi thấy bây giờ tôi vẫn được ngồi máy
tính cả ngày nên tôi thích điều đấy đúng
không nó khác biệt
xóa Ờ ông Tùng Phạm xóa
à gì đấy
tắt
lời
đi tôi tranh thủ trả lời vài
người có kinh nghiệm như nào để có người
ta chia sẻ tận tình ạ hỏi kiểu hỏi làm
sao cho đúng đấy ạ Ừ cái này là
có bạn trả lời ngay dưới tì hiểu kỹ
trước khi hỏi đúng đấy một cái này Thực
ra thì tôi hồi trước tôi cũng bị hỏi rất
nhiều đặc biệ hồi làm kiểm duyệt nhóm J2
team community thì tức cả nhóm Ấy nhóm
với công nghệ mà rất nhiều người thực C
vào đấy không phải đều là dân công nghệ
nên cứ nghĩ là vào đấy sẽ hỏi đáp đế mọi
thứ Nên là kiểu đăng bài hỏi thậm chế
inbox hỏi x thậm chí là kể inbox Tại sao
không được không được duyệt cái bài hỏi
vân vân n thứ thì hồi đấy là tôi cũng
Kiền nhận tận tình trả lời hết các thứ
các thứ đó là nhưng mà đương nhiên là
vẫn giúp kin nghiệm cho các bạn đấy có
nhiều thứ đó là thứ nhất là các bạn
phải muốn trả muốn câu trả lời có tâm
các bạn sẽ phải hỏi một cách hỏi cách có
tâm thế nào là hỏi cách có tâm tức là
các bạn phải đặt đặt vị trí của người
trả lời mình và câu hỏi thôi nghĩa là em
không thể hỏi những cái mà kiểu đến
chính em không biết được nên trả lời như
thế nào đấy Kiểu thế đương nhiên là mình
không biết cầu trả lời nên mình hỏi nhá
chỉ là kiểu câu hỏi đấy khó quá khoai
quá Vân Vân
à
à và đặc biệt là hỏi một cách kiểu vu vơ
quá ví dụ hồi trước tô từng thấy có rất
nhiều người chụp cho tôi cái màn hình
sao vậ kiểu Anh ơi làm cái này như th
nào kiểu đấy là một màn hình Tôi vẫn nhớ
là đấy là màn hình trang YouTube chẳng
hạn đấy Kiểu không biết được câu hỏi của
bạn ấy nhấn mạnh vào cái gì ý làm trang
web YouTube à Xong rồi Bạn ấy còn đang
ngồi xem video đánh đàn guitar nữa
kiểu làm cái này là làm cái nào không
kiểu kiểu như thế nghĩa là kiểu bạn Ừ
thì theo cách xếp của tôi thường hay nói
đó là cái gì mà khó quá thì mình Hãy đẩy
cái vấn đề đấy sang cho người khác thả
Khuyết mình không giải quyết được mình
đẩ vấn đề sang người khác nhưng mà cái
vấn đề bạn đấy Kiểu như thế kiểu bạn ấy
còn mông lung về cái vấn đề của bạn đấy
không biết được vấn đề của bạn ấy nên
như nào bạn ấy đẩy cái cái gọi là cái mớ
vấn đề đấy cho người khác thì rất nhiều
người sẽ né cái đấy đi người ta không
đón nhận nó đâu ngườ ta không Chưa chắc
người ta nhiệt tình để mà kiểu hỗ trợ
bạn đâu đúng không Đặc biệt bạn là người
lạ mà Đấy đương nhiên là tôi vẫn hỗ trợ
trả lời các thứ tôi vẫn phải hỏi kỹ lại
là thực sự em muốn hỏi gì Vân vân vân
đấy đấy thứ nhất bạn phải nên làm rõ câu
hỏi thứ hai đó là bạn phải tìm hiểu
trước câu hỏi có thể bạn tìm hiểu đúng
hay sai thì bạn vẫn phải nói qua là em
đã tìm hiểu cái này cái này làm bước này
này Đấy trình bày rõ ra chi tiết Càng
tốt để mà thể hiện rõ được
hiệu trước nhưng mà áp dụng không thành
công hoặc là áp dụng sai bước thì người
ta còn biết cách đừng có nói mấy câu
chung chung là kiểu em đã thử hết mọi
cách trên Google nhưng không được Nếu mà
giả sử em thực sự tìm hiểu được mọi cách
và em tra được Google đúng mà nó không
được ấy thì đúng là anh khuyên em nên
đập máy nghỉ rõ ràng là thằng Google nó
không hỗ trợ được em Anh không nghĩ anh
hỗ trợ được em có sự thật là như thế
thường là các bạn có thể tra Google
Nhưng mà tra từ khóa sai hai là các bạn
tra Google Nhưng mà áp dụng sai cách đấy
các bạn phải nói rõ các bạn đã áp dụng
như nào và các bạn Trang Tử khán như nào
đấy thử những cách gì rồi đấy đừng nói
mấy câu kiểu Chưa gì đã chưa gì đ đã gọi
là rào trước như thế đúng không đấy hoặ
Chỉ đơn giản Hồi trước khi mà tôi đi
thực tập tôi hỏi hỏi nhiều mà tôi hỏi
kinh khủng nhiều đấy thì tôi sẽ hỏi là
kiểu em định làm cái đoạn này tính năng
là như này ví dụ Giả sử kiểu Em muốn làm
cái bật lên được cái cửa sổ hiển thị lên
chẳng ạ Em không biết từ khóa nó là gì
và không biết là nên áp dụng công nghệ
gì hoặc là em nghĩ là áp dụng ra scrip
nhưng mà nhưng mà không biết đúng hay
không thì anh cho em từ khóa em tự tìm
hiểu đấy thế thôi thế là xong anh sẽ cho
mình từ khóa rồi có thể gửi mình được
link tài nện liệu là quá quý rồi đấy X
mình sẽ tìm hiểu còn nếu mình còn gặp
vấn đề nữa thì mình làm xong mình thử
một vài cách vẫn không được mình l quay
hỏi anh ấy tiếp là em áp dụng kiểu kiểu
này nhưng mà nó chỉ ra được thế này thôi
Em chưa biết làm gì tiếc anh hỗ trợ em
để em xem để em còn kiểu biết cách cách
đb th thứ đấy Nói thế xong mộ T đố ông
nào kiểu trừ khi ông ấy kiểu tư thù ông
lắm ch Ông Nà sẽ sẵn là trả lời thôi
đúng không
tôi nói đúng kiểu cái giọng trên công ty
tôi hay hỏi và hay làm đấy thấy cũng
kiểu nghẹ mượt mượt xôi tai mà đúng
không sẵn ra hỗ trợ tôi chưa các bạn các
bạn nhân viên ơi các bạn hỗ trợ mình
Lương 1 ha tháng có ổn không 1 hai tháng
bình thường mà không vấn đề gì cả hồi
trước là tôi làm bị bóc lột đến 6 tháng
tôi cũng phải cân nhắc việc nghỉ cơ mà
bởi vì tôi cảm thấy phải đến cái lúc mà
tôi cảm thấy không còn học được mấy nữa
thì tôi mới nghỉ thôi
đấy còn không thì
mình đang chấp nhận là bị bóc lột thì
đúng nhưng mà thực ra người ta có mất
thời gian để đào tạo mình mà người ta có
được gì từ mình đâu Bình thường mình đi
học Mình còn trả tiền học cho trường hay
các thứ các thử Cò đây người ta đào tạo
mình thì mình trả gì cho người ta đấy
nên là nó bài toàn anh đổ trừ khi là
người ta không đa tạo được gì cho em thì
đúng là em nên nghỉ chỗ đấy Thật đấy CN
không thì đôi bên cũng có lợi mà đúng
không
Ờ đúng rồi Không tôi tôi thườ anh nói
tới đam mê Nhưng đúng là có nhiều người
không thực sự là không may mắn để mà gặp
được đúng đam mê lẫn cả là tôi còn gặp
rất nhiều người nghĩa là có đam mê nhưng
mà người ta không gặp được người người
thầy à người mental người chỉ dẫn dìu
dắt à Không gặp được cả người đồng hành
các thứ thứ để hỗ trợ được cho người ta
để mà người
ta kiểu mông lung ấy
nế thành ra người ta cũng ngại ngại
không phải người nào cũng khả năng tự
học tốt không phải người nào cũng kiểu
bám vững được bởi vì người ta còn bị bài
toán áp lực rất nhiều thứ áp lực kinh tế
áp lực nhiều thứ nữa nên là hơi khó để
mà nói là làm mọi thứ theo đam mê của
mình nhưng
mà chắc chắn là mình phải thích nó đã
bởi vì nó là một cái công việc mà mình
tốn
1/3 ngày mỗi ngày đấy Kể cả Mư nắng vân
vân mình vẫn phải làm đấy là kiểu giờ
đây là đang nói mức độ bình thường của
giời hành chính các thứ nhá nhiều người
ở đây tôi biết là làm một lúc hai ba
việc các thứ thứ cầy các thứ thứ còn mệt
hơn vân vân thì cái đấy tôi Tôi nghĩ là
tôi may mắn hơn rất nhiều người thế nên
là tôi mới nếu có thế nên là bây giờ tôi
mới kiểu hỗ trợ được bạn nào tôi vẫn sẵn
sàng hỗ trợ và hỗ trợ đương nhiên là với
Tứ cách kiểu miễn phí Nếu có thể à Thứ
nếu có thể Thôi nhá vẫn đang miễn phí mà
nhưng mà con trẻ vẫn hỗ trợ nhề tình các
thứ để cho vì tôi may mắn hơn vài người
như thế Tôi may mắn ở đây không phải may
mắn về tôi đầy đủ điều kiện hơn tôi
không nghĩ như thế tôi xuất thân đến bây
giờ đến bây giờ tôi vẫn chưa có gì cả
nhưng mà nh là tôi không bị áp lực ở mấy
cái kia nên là Tô và tôi gặp
được được đúng người ừ hôm nay tôi nói
vụ đấy Đó là Tôi nghĩ là tôi đang đi
được đúng đường vì rõ ràng là tôi gặp
được đúng đúng người đúng lúc rất nhiều
lúc là tôi gặp vấn đề gì đó đều có người
có thể hỗ trợ được cho tôi tôi may
mắn ông bạn này sinh năm bao nhiêu chào
ông cũng tên Long Tôi sinh năm
chẳng biết là tôi có đam mê mánh tính
mấy dòng code không Tôi tôi nghĩ tôi đam
mê về cái logic hay mọi thứ xử lý kiểu
thế
hơn xông thiếu thốn các kiểu mà đi làm
như vì đam mê không quan tâm tiền bạc ch
Lắm đúng nếu mà mình kiểu mình đam mê à
mình kiểu thực sự hướng đến cái khác ví
dụ hướng đến ví dụ tôi bây giờ đang
hướng đến là muốn hiểu rõ muốn hiểu sâu
hơn muốn làm mọi thứ tốt hơn này thì
chình mình nâng lên chừng mình nâng lên
thì thì sẽ được đãi ngộ lại một cách
xứng đáng
luôn quan niệm rằng cái mình nghĩ ra là
lỗi mình gặp phải đều có người giải
thích rồi Đúng chứ khi em gặp lỗi em lắm
thường sẽ có người đã từng gặp phải em
may may các bạn là chưa đến cái giai
đoạn các bạn gặp những cái lỗi mà còn
mình người đầu tiên gặp đâu Tôi đã từng
gặp những K quả như thế rồi tra không ra
luôn đấy các bạn hãy ra quan là tôi nghĩ
là bạn chưa đến cái ngưỡng người đâu lúc
đấy mới gọ có vấn đề thực sự đấy Còn bây
giờ thì cứ thoải mái lên tài liệu mọi
thứ nhăn Nhàn chỉ sợ là nhiều quá các
bạn không chắt lọc được thôi các bạn sấy
bị có tải
IDE vs code trên ma không ạ Tôi không
dùng cộng c th cộng mấy nữa tôi Tôi nghĩ
là sẽ có người hỗ trợ được cho bạn rủ
đấy đấy
à Hỏi trên server discord hoặc là hỏi
cho GT nhá Hình như là chắc nó sẽ gợi ý
thôi Anh có Ui về web hay di động đẹp
không ạ Không tôi không lưu mấy cái
template đấy lắm khi chán code thì anh
thường làm gì ạ câu hỏi rất là hay vì
tính ra tôi chưa chán code tôi chỉ có
kiểu lúc đau não quá quá không không Cốt
đế nữa thôi thì tôi khi những khi như
thế là tôi sẽ kiểu cố để cho tâm trạng
mình thoải mái kiểu thả lỏng làm những
cái việc khác có thể là gần đây thì đúng
là hơi mất Hôm nay cũng có bạn hỏi tôi
là ngoài làm việc ra thì anh đam mê Cái
gì khác anh thấy cái gì thứ gì khác thú
vị cuộc sống thì tôi đúng là tôi gần đây
tôi hơi bị mất động lực hơi mất nhiều
cái thế Hôm nay định nói cũng là như
tôi gần đây tôi không hn mất Vương ngược
nhưng tôi bị mất động lực thật tôi có
thể luôn trướ trước mặt mọi người như
này tôi là con người năng động tích cực
nên tôi nghĩ gần đây tôi có có một tí
dấu hiệu Tôi cảm thấy là tính tôi bị
trầm lại có thể trầm cảm hay gì đó về
chắc là khép mình lại nhiều nó không
tốt
cần mình thấy dấu hiệu như thế là mình
phải bắt đầu thấy không ổn và mình phải
thay đổi thay đổi mọi thói quen hàng
ngày thôi để sao cho để sao cho mà nó
thay đổi kết quả
với vài anh em hôm nay có cái kèo đi cà
phê ấ không biết chắc là mấy ông không
để ý đúng không có kèo cà phê đấy xế kèo
cà phê này đấy lên đây gặp được anh em
không ai tâm sự các thứ các thứ vui phết
nên là cũng kiểu thoải mái thả lỏng hơn
tôi cảm thấy là À đúng rồi nữa Dạo này
Tôi đã cho phép bản thân
mình
à Tôi cho phép bản thân mình được
à được thước khuya gần đây được thế
thành ra là nó bị kiểu Chắc chắn là do
mình khi thước khuya mình kiểu âm khí
hay cái gì gì đó lại kh không phải năng
lượng tích cực thời gian đấy vì lý trí
lúc ấy còn trùng xuống mà
trầm cảm lên ngôi ch lý trí rù xuống ấy
đấy Nên là kiểu buổi tối thì anh thì
mình dễ
bị suy nghĩ nhiều x cảm thấy cảm thấy
bất ổn nhiều cái
đấy Nên là
à nên là tôi nghĩ là tôi phải thay đổi
dần về lại thói quen đó mình phải dậy
sớm hơn về tính là thường chẳng ai trầm
cảm đúng sáng sớm rồi đúng không kiểu
sáng dậy thôi k ôi trầm cảm quá à không
chắc cùng lắm là kiểu thôi buồn ngủ quá
muốn ngủ tiếp thôi
không như em tưởng tượng Sao tưởng tượng
gì mấy ông tôi không biết mấy ông tưởng
tượng gì thực ra trên Facebook tôi Tôi
công khai ảnh mà n chắc chắn không kiểu
trông tấu Hai giải trí như này rồi à đấy
Đây để tôi thấp xuống cho để lộ ảnh à vơ
này à không đây vẫn nghe được đúng không
ạ Nếu mà mấy bạn bị nghe dè do kiểu
tiếng quạt thì nhớ bảo tôi
tôi 97 mà như 91
đây nhưng mà sáng này dè từ đầu
biết đấy đỡ chưa
ạ sa mấy cái quạt đấy đ ấy được rồi để
hôm sau tôi sẽ cơ cầu kiểu mở điều hòa
cho nhiệt độ
ở miền Bắc bây giờ không ổn vẫn rẻ vẫn
ổn
được
nghe gì Alo ạ Alo ạ Ừ cái này nó còn
thay đổi đợi đợi tôi một tí Đợi tôi một
tí đ không
em
ducky trợ về cái vụ setup cái mic này
sau Ờ nói chung là trong chuyên nghiệp
hơn một tí
anh em jha mấy cái anh em kiểu hacker
các th thứ thì mấy anh đấy anh em mấy
gặp ngoài đời ngầu thật trừ shop Hưng Em
xin lỗi shop Hưng nhưng mà sop Hưng em
gặp trong giải trí
lắm Anh có ngầu như mà luôn giải trí tấu
hài trong mắt em Em xin
mày s Hưng rồi rồi có lý do tự nhiên tôi
gọi đến SH Hưng mà shop Hưng giải trí
vãi trưởng con người con người gọi là
tính cách thoải mái rất là thoải mái rất
dễ tin người nữa đỉnh vãi Vẫn kiểu Nghe
sự tích anh đấy và gặp anh ấy ngoài đời
nên biết được qua thực anh ấy hacker anh
ấy cũng không hẳn là dễ ttin người như
thế đâu Không phải kiểu không dễ lộ
thông tin n mọi thứ đâu Nhưng quan trọng
là khi mà cả Anh ấy cảm thấy tin được
mình rồi cho hết mọi thứ buồn cười nó
chyện sâu Hưng tấu
Hai các bạn chắc là không biết sâ Hưng
nhưng mà các bạn có biết g hai team
community đúng không ạ bết g hai team
rồi thì sub hưng chính là anh J game anh
à Thì J2 thì viết tắt của Juno và anh
Juno và James đúng không Thì s Hưng anh
James anh cả hai anh đều cùng làm cùng
công ty tôi bây giờ thì lúc đầu tôi thân
với anh Tuấn hơn xong rồi về làm công ty
các thứ thứ còn nhưng mà về sau đến bây
giờ thì tôi thân với s Hưng kiểu vì anh
ấy hỗ trợ tôi rất nhiều vân vân và anh
em thỉnh thoảng giao lưu chơi game hoặc
là giao lưu tâm sự các thứ nhiều và thực
ra tính của anh đấy Thì đúng là dễ kiểu
dễ thân các thứ được hơn thật thì anh ấy
cũng khi mà tôi cảm thấy ở đấy tôi cảm
thấy khi mà tôi ở cạnh mấy cái người
hướng nội mấy người đấy Nói nhiều thế
nói hết cả phần của mình
kiểu mấy người kiểu mangc tiếng hướng
nội nhưng mà kiểu khi thân được khi kiểu
quen mình
rồi nói nhiều kinh
khủng đấy Tôi vẫn nhớ kiểu Tôi phải quay
ăn nói Sếp của tôi là kiểu để em em kiếm
việc cho anh làm nhé đển hình ạ
xin phép thập sự tì Uầy rất nhiều link
nghĩ là tôi điểu khi mở được
cái khi mở được cái Facebook thì tôi sẽ
kiểu chia sẻ bớt cái link này thô thế
bây giờ vẫn chưa mở được tôi tính xong
nhé đầu tiên thì gần đây tôi có trải
nghiệm đi du lịch một mình đú kết ra
được vài
cái một
là luôn phải đặt trước mọi thứ nhưng
đừng có nên đặt quá App vì tính là đặt
quá mất thên phí ạ Cái thật nên kiểu gọi
đi trực tiếp hay gì tí đó đặt CH nó đơn
giản hơn đặc biệt là không phải mua du
lịch hôm nay tôi đi cũng vào cuối tuần
nhưng mà tôi đi ở Vĩnh
Phúc không phải chỗ du lịch nên thành
cũng phải cũng thoải mái hơn không không
cần phải nhất thiết đặt mọi thứ như thế
Tôi đặt quá App các thứ đề phòng các th
thứ cuối cùng thì đến đấy thực ra có khi
mình cũng chỉ là một trong số ít người
đặt ở đấy Nên là thừa phòng rất nhiều và
mình đặt thì đắt hơn một tí thứ hai đó
là lên kế hoạch mọi thứ may Tôi là Quan
tôi lên kế hoạch hết rồi Rồi chủ quan đó
là lên kế hoạch cho việc đi đâu Hay là
ăn gì hay các th thứ mà xung quanh có
nhưng mà chưa hề lường trước xung quanh
chẳng có gì cả Lạc quan là may mà ở cái
khch khách sạn Tôi đặt thì họ còn có
riêng một quầy đầy đầu tiên tôi thấy
trong khách sạn mà có cả quầy bán snack
có thử thứ kiểu nó gọ nó gọi là minim
max đấy Kiểu một cái S dị nhỏ ở đấy Bán
vài cái kiểu nhiều cái đôi khi là chỉ mì
tôm rồi Các th thứ đấy cũng khá là hay
tiếp theo là gì ấy nhở đặt phòng lần này
đặt hơi phòng hơi sang chành quá Công
nhận là cũng được chái nh nhiệm rất
nhiều cái lần đầu thấy quả ở Việt Nam có
cái kiểu bồn cầu của giống kiểu Nhật kểu
có mấy cái nút kiểu tự vệ sinh hay
hay nhưng mà không quen Đạ Đúng là vòi
xịt vẫn ở trên
ái còn thêm gì nhỉ nói chung là tự nhiên
kiểu Tôi may mà Bây giờ tôi cũng có điều
kiện để tôi thử đi mấy cái kiểu như thế
Một Mình Thế hôm n hứng lên kiểu có ngày
nghỉ đi kiểu như thế Tự trải nghiệm à
Cũng đọng lại được khá nhiều suy nghĩ
trải nghiệm thì không nhiều đâu chủ yếu
đọc nh đọc lại nhiều suy nghĩ vì rõ ràng
là đi Có đúng một hôm thôi cũng không
thể nhiều để mà có quá nhiều đú kết cho
mấy ông cả nhưng mà hôm đấy tôi đã định
hôm đấy tôi lại livestream cho mấy ông
rồi Ngay tại ngay tại chỗ đấy bì trông
khoang cảnh nó chắc chắn đẹp hơn ở đây
vì nó là phòng Cũng xịn mà đấy nhưng mà
à hôm đấy hôm ấy tính là vì chưa Chuẩn
bị được cái gì cả thì hôm thôi Tôi nghĩ
là nhưng mà Đây cũng là một cái dấu hiệu
đầu này để tôi từng nói mấy ông đó là
tôi sẽ Quay vlog nhiều hơn quay kiểu có
thể livestream hoặc quay lại video có
thơ dớ không biết quay lại video như thế
nào vì tôi cũng hơi bị lười tôi rất rất
lười ngủ bỏ thời gian ra để mà ngồi mồi
chỉnh sửa cái gì gì đó bởi tính ra thì
đương nhiên là mên tự mình chỉnh sửa tự
mình học cái đấy nhưng mà ý tôi là tôi
cảm thấy là v cái đấy tôi những cái gì
tôi hôm nay tôi cũng ngồi nói chuyện với
anh em thế đó là những cái gì mà tôi
không giỏi lắm thì tôi
sẽ tôi sẽ đẩy cái tôi sẽ nhờ cái đấy để
cho cái người nào có chuyên môn hơn để
làm hộ tôi tôi sẽ có thời gian để làm
việc khác mà tôi giỏi đúng chế ngành
Nhưng mà thực ra thì ừ nhiều người khác
tôi một phần là ngại một phần là sợ là
người ta không đúng ý mình không biết
thế nào như nhưng mà biết đâu lại hay
nếu mà giả sử nhờ người khác mà người ta
có thêm góp nhìn khác người ta góp ý
Mình cũng hay mình tự thân vận động làm
hết mọi thứ thì vừa là ưu vừa là Nhược
nhược là tự mình làm tự mình khên hay
không đánh giá
được quay kỷ niệm thôi Ai xem xem à
không Thực ra tôi không quan trọng việc
ai xem xem tôi gọi nhiều người TH ng để
ý Kiểu lượt xem của video mình như nào
tôi có tôi bảo tôi có để ý cái điều đấy
tôi tôi xem mà nhưng mà tôi để ý theo
kiểu dạng là xem là mình có vấn đề gì
không mà lượng lượng Xem giảm hay tăng
gì gì đó để mình mình cải thiện đúng
không Nhưng mà còn việc việc dạng nh tôi
có sợ người khác không xem hay không thì
là không chỉ có một người xem hoặ gì
không ai xem được Tôi vẫn tự mình tăng
gần như như là đây là trang cá nhân mà
đây blog mà tức là Trang Lưu lại mọi thứ
tôi không quan trọng việc
là là nó đang hướng đối tượng dạng như
nào Tôi đang hướng đối tượng của trong
cái của cái kênh này hay của mọi thứ của
tôi nó là chia sẻ góc nhìn của cuộc sống
xung quanh mình với góc nhìn là dân công
nghệ hay thứ thứ vân
vân cái này tôi thấy là gần đây tôi thấy
là
bên nước ngoài bây giờ không phải bên
nước ngoài Chính xác là người người tôi
tôi có theo dõi thì phải kênh kiểu người
Việt mình ở bên nước ngoài cũng chia sẻ
rất nhiều nhưng mà chẳng ai chia sẻ ở
Việt Nam
cả một thứ hai là người ta chia sẻ người
ta nói về chủ đề khác còn tôi nói chủ đề
có thể đôi khi là có liên quan đến chính
trị hay là vẫn nó đế khoa học hay gì đó
góc nhìn của tôi mà kiến thức của tôi mà
mấy người kia tôi thấy là người ta chỉ
dám nói về chuyên ngành của ta chyên môn
người ta vì người ta nghĩ là nói cái đấy
người khác mới muốn nghe và nói cái đấy
họ mới đúng ở chuyên môn của họ thì họ
mới dám nói Còn tôi thì tôi tìm hiểu
cũng nhiều mạng nên là tôi sẽ nói về
nhiều thứ các bạn thỉnh thoảng lên đây
ngồi anh em sẽ có một cái gì đó trao đổi
tôi Ann định là có khi là tôi hôm vào
ngoài nói kiểu này tôi sẽ mời vài anh em
kiểu kiểu tạo
à kiểu vào kênh discord này này xong rồi
kiểu mấy anh em mở mic rồi anh em ngồi
nói chuyện luôn trong đấy cũng vui hay
mà kiểu thế Cái này gần đây là tôi chắc
là tôi cũng bị à tác động bởi anh Độ
misi à anh cũng có kiểu thế cho anh em
vào nói chuyện các thứ các thứ cũng được
mà
nhỉ Mấy cái link này tôi quên mất là có
nên bấm hay không rồi ta tạm bỏ qua à
Tôi đang không chia sẻ màn hình nhá Mấy
ông không thấy được nhỉ Không sao mấy
ông bấm vàoo link kia mấy ông thấy đấy à
tôi nói mày cũng để ý
thôi thế Tự nhiên là đây Tôi nghe ngắn
gọn streamer bán hàng nhỉ Đợi tôi một tí
Đợi tôi một tí Hello xin chào tất cả các
bạn nhá Nhìn video ơ m không nghe được
tiếng không anh như tôi tắt tiếng rồi
đợi tí tôi xem lại video này đã Tại sao
tôi tôi ghi lại cái này
nhỉ có tiếng á
ơ Tôi nhớ tôi tắt tiểu mà
là đây là Ờ anh đúng rồi anh pi piu lúc
đầu th ra
tôi tôi gọi như nào Tôi không muốn các
thân tượng của tôi vị công nghiệp hóa
này đương nhiên là ai cũng có đụng Vì
cơm áo gạo tiền vì r r money thôi đấy cỡ
má gạ ti Ừ đúng rồi r m đấy nhưng mà
nhưng mà tôi sợ là kiểu cái đồng tiền nó
sẽ dễ làm cho mình kiểu không còn là
chính mình nữa mình sẽ bị thaam hóa Vân
Vân Vân đấy rất nhiều cái để mình không
không còn tự nhiên được nữa ấ đấy đúng
không
Ờ nhưng
mà anh đấy vẫn giữ được mọi thứ và cảm
thấy anh Đương nhiên là có thay đổi có
thay đổi ai chẳng thay đổi à Tôi thấy
trưởng thành chính chắn hơn và lại phù
hợp với chị Hiếu số đông hơn không biết
là mấy ông thấy tốt hay xấu tôi lại cám
thấy là anh đấy có nhiều thứ làm tôi
không phản tôi sẽ học tập bây giờ chúng
ta chuyển qua bán hàng đâu nhá
Ờ nhưng mà anh đấy
Nói chung là không biết là do tôi hay do
anh đấy Hay vân vân khế tôi có góp nhìn
rất khác về việc là làm streamer rồi bán
hàng Hy nhắc đến vụ tiền bạc dù là tôi
là người rất nhạy cảm và dị ứng với nhắc
đến tiền bạc ti N các thử vì cảm thấy
là kênh nào đại khái Hồi trước ấ mế hình
dung kênh nào mà cứ nhắc đến kiểu quảng
cáo gì gì đâu V theo dõi không có tâm vì
tôi nghĩ là kênh này đã bị mua rồi nh
kiểu thế kiểu gì sẽ biến chất thôi đấy
như là anh P là một trong những người mà
kiểu tôi cũng thân tượng nên An kiểu khi
mà anh livestream mà cá thứ này cũng có
sự tấu hải của anh đấy tôi vẫn xem tôi
không xem livestream nhưng tôi xem lại
mấy cái kiểu Highlight hay là tôi có
theo dõi kênh đấy các thứ thì rất là hay
nó chung
là tôi không hề nói là tôi sẽ về sau mua
bán cái gì và tôi cũng không ý định là
sẽ mua bán gì đâu có thể à Có thể là tôi
nó nói chuyện như đa cấp đấy nhưng mà
chưa biết thế nào không hứa cái gì tôi
cũng không định hướng về mấy cái điều
đấy Không phải tôi bảo rồi ấy Không phải
buổi hôm nay buổi nhá trước là tôi sẽ
chuẩn bị livestream bán hàng không nhá
Không có gì để bán
mấy ông chưa biết thì tôi bị bay mất tài
khoản chính Facebook thôi gần đây mới
tạo nick clon ra nữa x bị bay cay thật
nghĩ là kiểu IP tôi có về vấn đề gì đó Ờ
vừa nãy Vừa reset lại mua router rồi
Không biết có nên làm gì nữa không có
người bảo phải cài lại máy để mà thay
đổi địa chỉ m
đấy chưa biết được nhưng mà
Ờ Thì đại khái thì tôi cũng khá là chủ
quan khi mà ngoài việc là mình lưu lại
khá nhiều thứ kỷ niệm mọi thứ trên đấy
là cả thông tin liên lạc nhiều người thứ
thế Đáng lẽ mình phải tìm chỗ để mà
backup lại hay Vân Vân đúng không ạ thứ
hai đó đó là
Ừ mình bị chủ quan là là mình bị phụ
thuộc vào cái mạng xã hội đấy quá mạng
xã hội đấy có vấn đề gì đó thì mình mình
đấy Bây giờ mình đang đang phải cố lấy
lại đấy Kiểu thế đáng nẽ mình không nên
phụ thuộc cái gì đấy Có đầy mạng xã hội
mà đã chuẩn là không có cái này tao nhảy
sang cái khác đương nhiên là hoặc C chỉ
đơn giản là tôi không nên quan trọng hóa
nó quá kiểu tôi hoàn toàn thể tạo nick
clon để mà liên hệ lại những cái người
thân của tôi trên đấy nhưng mà bây giờ
giờ bị bây giờ bị mất mà nên mình không
nhớ được nick người thân như nào đểu
mình mình nhắn tin ấy
đấy và cái thứ ba đó
là tôi còn đăng nhập vài cái nick của
tôi bằng Facebook đúng không ạ Đấy mất
thầy thì T đó cảm
thấy ít nhất là nick l l may là vẫn dùng
email được nhưng mà vài nick khác đề tôi
C không nhớ ví dụ là gì à hand fingle
Hình như là không không vào được n này
đại khái thế đương nhiên là có thể liên
hệ với mấy cái bên đấy là tôi bị mất
nick kiểu cho tôi đăng nhập lại bằng
Email hay không th cũng có rất nhiều
cách nhưng mà HM chỉ là kiểu Nó là một
cái vấn đề mà đúng không Và thực ra là
tôi C không biết là mấy trang đấy có cho
đăng nhập lại bằng Email hay không cơ
nghĩa là có thể mấy Trang Đấy cũng là
lỗi code của người ta nữa n chuẩn
là code là đăng ký tài khoản bằng mạng
xã hội khác tức cả đăng ký cái đấy bằng
email nhưng mà có vẻ nhiều thằng nó
không làm thế nó đăng ký đúng bằng mạng
xã hội khác nghĩa là và đăng ký Email là
một hai tài khoản khác nhau luôn tôi
biết có vài trang là như thế không biết
là nó là tốt hay là dở nhưng theo tôi
thế nó không tiện lắm khi mình bị mất
mạng xã hội đúng
không nẽ là không thấy mấy ông bình luận
thì là mấy ông không bình luận hay là do
tôi mạng có vấn đề đấy Tôi phải tải
trang lại
Ok thỉ thoảng chấm một cái cũng được
không sao đâu đây bên này không phải J2
đâu Chắc là chấm thoải mái được đừng
chấm spam được
mấy ông là như thế tôi cảm thấy đấy
giống như anh Độ hay nói gần đây gần đây
là anh nó anh cũng bị có vấn đề gì đó về
kênh hay các thứ bị hack th đấy đúng
không anh cũng nói theo kiểu làô coi như
tôi là học Đắc giá thì cho m Ông kểu
thấy tấm Khương để đừng mắc phải thôi bị
khóa Facebook bởi vì chạy mấy cái tool
Facebook đấy không nên chạy Cái đấy trên
nick
chính
lon Tôi vẫn nhớ cái quả Hồi trước cũng
có một ông hỏi trên
J2 ông này có đăng bài hỏi là từ năm
2017 phải B Đồng B hỏi là em muốn thử
tính năng tổ cáo của Facebook xo em tạo
nick clon xo em dùng nick clon tổ cáo
nick chính và anh ngờ bay luôn nick
chính rất nhiều người vào bình luận là
kiểu đấy Sao không dùng nick
clon à nick chính tố cáo nick clon mà
ngược lại nhưng mà chắc là nick ông rồi
bây giờ đủ lâu để thành nick chính rồi
đấy đấy Nói chung là làm cái gì đó mình
đôi khi mình phải lôi clon ra bi không ạ
Dùng ních chính hơi dễ toát
đó mình gọi là chủ quan quan trọng vẫn
là chủ quan thôi tiếp
Ờ nói chung là ngày tầm tầm này đúng rồi
Tầm này năm ngoái tôi có đi
offline Online fan club của
H bộ phim series khá nổi đấy Thì đại
khái thì tôi có đi offline đấy Có rất
nhiều người cùng chung sở thích phim với
mình Mình rất là thích và trong đó Đương
nhiên là lần đấy là tôi có dẫn theo bạn
gái nhưng mà bạn đấy bạn mới quen thôi
Kiểu cũng mới hẹn họ tìm hiểu đấy thì
hôm đấy may mà dẫn được bạn ấy đi cùng
cùng đam
mê rồi
À hôm đấy Kiểu có thi cái cuộc thi hóa
trang gì gì đó Bởi vì hôm ấy tôi mặc
cũng giống một nhân vật ông đấy nên tôi
cũng đăng ký tham gia rồi X rồi hóa ra
ai đăng ký cũng đều được lên sân khấu
đấy Xong
đến bây giờ tôi vẫn nhớ đó tôi không
biết được à nên cảm ơn hay không nên
chắc chắn là tôi khẳng định MC như thế
nó hơi khiến cho mình và đúng là tôi
cũng nghĩ việc là nếu về sau tôi mà nổi
tiếng mà tôi tôi phải cẩn thận trong
việc phát ngôn mà tôi Cẩn thận trong
việc dễ dính bẫy của MC kiểu như thế mấy
ông ông MC hỏi tôi câu đó
là bạn có coi bạn g bạn bạn này là the
one của bạn không kiểu the one ở trong
phim ấy Nó không chỉ dừng lại mỗi nửa
kia đâu phải là một người đối với tôi ấ
đối với tôi hiểu ý nghĩa phim đấy one là
một người rất là hoàn hảo một cái kiểu
người mình Xẽ sà lấy là vợ thậm chí còn
kiểu hơn cả thế các thử thử à đương
nhiên bạn đấy tôi mới quen và tôi cũng
chưa nghĩ chưa thể nghĩ đến việc là kiểu
cưới bạn đấy hay gì cả nên là tôi bị
khựng lại ở câu đấy Mọi người lúc đấy ở
dưới thì mọi
người thường là khán giả số đông thường
đặc biệt thích bộ phim này nữa thường ng
hướng đến là kiểu happy ending đúng
không kiểu có chuyện có kiểu cảm động ý
nghĩa thế mọi người sẽ rất muốn câu trả
lời nó có thể như này lúc đấy Tôi nghĩ
là thật ra thực ra tôi có thể nói dối
được nhưng là tôi đã trong một vài giây
đấy Tôi đã nghĩ rất nhiều trường hợp hay
mình nói rối nhỉ nó rối cứ nói bừa là
kiểu cứ nói bừa thức ra lờ Nói Dố Vô Hại
chắc là không ai kiểm chứng đâu Chắc
không ai quay lại giống kiểu Harry w là
là em chắc chắn
đâu nhưng
mà hay nói bừa kiểu bạn đấy là cá thử
thử nhở
đấy mà không Tôi đã nói là tôi đang tôi
đang cân nh Xem sét hai cái thớ thớ
Ê sao sao có gì nhạy cảm tôi đang nói gì
đó sai Tự nhiên
hay mất mất sóng á mất sóng
kia Ê xong rồi không nói gì nữa ban Ngại
nhỉ Có nào nó bình luận để tôi biết được
mấy ông đang nghe đi ạ
tưởng như đầu cắt moi
thôi thấy hơi xấu không biết bây giờ ch
trông
đang xem xét C nhá Đấy cứ thử thử xong
ngồi à Kiểu ở dưới kiểu ô lên kiểu thứ
thứ X cảm thấy là kiểu ừ
vậ mình bị mất hình ảnh mình tạo ấn
tượng xấu thật
đấy không nhận cảnh nghĩ lại thằng thằng
MC chời khăm quả Câ hỏi vãi chưng Thực
ra lúc ấy tôi đang kiểu cố giải thích là
kiểu với tôi mới quen bà đấy thôi gi C
lúc đấy Kiểu khán giả không muốn nghe
khán giả chỉ muốn kiểu kết thúc hó hậu
kiểu mọi người kiểu yếu nhau rồi kết hôn
các th các thứ để họ nhìn vào vững cảnh
kiểu màu hồng thôi Thế nên là tôi cảm
thấy Đấy là nếu về sau mà tôi mà nổi nổi
tí một là tôi phải bản trước với Mc là
sẽ nên trả lời câu gì hai không trả lời
đấy hoặc là không Đương nhiên là mình
không thể gái bẫy mình cũng không thể
kiểu cứ nói dối trên đấy Kiểu Chắc chắn
đây là người t sẽ cưới được sai đúng
không mới mới quen một tháng
kểu bạn đấy là the one thì chỉ có thể
văn của CH boy thôi tôi coi tôi coi cái
nghĩa đặt định nghĩa the one của tôi rất
là nghĩa kiểu rất là quan trọng đúng như
nhân vật chính ở trong cái bộ phim này
luôn đó là cả đời mình đi tìm the one
các thử thử Ừ cái ông em xĩ mẹ hỏi câu c
không ai biết mình lúc đấy cả Nhưng mà
quan trọng là à Nhưng mà đại khái tôi
đấy Xong rồi Đúng là làm Bẽ mặt cả tôi
cả bạn gái tôi thật đấy Xong rồi Bạn ấy
về cũng dỗi thứ thứ nhưng mà thực ra lúc
đấy tôi có nói lại với bạn đấy các thứ
thứ rồi cũng nói là lý do t cái suy nghĩ
của tôi các thứ thứ thế rồi đấy thì bạn
đấy t Nói chung là tôi không phải là tôi
không quan trọng cái mối quan hệ đấy
nhưng mà Đúng là tôi chưa hề nghĩ đến nó
đấy thì tôi cũng có nói với bạn đấy à
rồi tôi cũng tự nhiên tôi nhớ lại cái
cảnh trong một cái bộ phim các bạn xem
cái phim em chư 18
chưa Hình như là tôi tôi nhớ cảnh đấy
hình như thế không nhớ lắm đại khái thì
ờ cái đoạn đấy là đoạn mà
kiểu nhân vật chính nam à Bị hỏi câu là
kiểu có muốn cưới người này không à Hay
g gì đó hay hay là anh hay em có thai
hay các thứ gì gì đó không nhớ lắm nó
không thể mở lên để đây để xem được đại
khái kiểu như thế làm cho nhân vậtt Nam
lúc đầu bị sốc là kiểu muốn kiểu buông
bỏ ấy muốn kiểu Muốn né tránh trốn tránh
trách nhiệm ấy nhưng về sau nhân vật nam
bình tĩnh lại n là nam thấy
là có khi mình đã đổ sẵn sàng có thể lúc
đấy lúc đấy mình chưa hề nghĩ đến nghĩ
mình chưa Chuẩn bị tâm lý thôi chứ không
phải là mình không muốn nhưng sau khi mà
thực sự nghĩ đến thì mình cảm thấy mình
sẵn sàng các thứ các thứ đấy nghĩa em
chỉ phải có cho mình nghĩ lên đã để
chuẩn bị tinh thần đã chứ hỏi một câu
vover thế khó ấy trả lời lắm trả lời lúc
đấy Đa phần là lươn nói dối thôi Kiểu
kiểu xã dao thôi
ấ thằng nào mà trả lời câu đấy một cách
rất là nhanh một là đã từng nghĩ đến rồi
hai là chém gió làm gì
kiểu bật ra kểu tôi tôi sẵn sàng cưới
bạn này cái
vover chịu chịu
ng Thái là
bẫy thôi cảm thấy à đấy tôi cảm thấy đấy
là một cái bài học may mắn nữa bài học
trước khi làm người nổi tiếng chuẩn bị
cho những tình huống đấy Anh nghĩ sao ra
trường
mới xin đi thực tập không sao cả em
nhưng mà anh bảo rồi thực ra là các bạn
nghĩ đến cái gì đấy Nó là một cái linh
cảm hay một cái gì đó một cái dấu hiệu
gì đó các bạn bạn phải nghĩ đế nó không
ạ thì một là em Chấm dứt được cái suy
nghĩ đấy thì tốt hai là em thấy có vấn
đề thật thì em cứ làm cái mà em cảm thấy
em nên làm em hỏi anh một người lạ một
người thực sự cũng chưa gặp em và chưa
hiểu em em hỏi bất kỳ người khác người
ta cũng chưa chắc hiểu em em chỉ có thể
tự em nhận ra được mình thực sự cần nên
làm gì lúc này và em nói em cùm lắm là
thay vì em hỏi là có nên làm
cái này không thì hãy hỏi là em nên làm
thế nào thì nó sẽ dễ hơn chứ còn hỏi là
nên làm hay không thì người ta không thể
quyết định thay em được Vì anh Anh không
hiểu được em là một và thứ hai là anh
không chịu trách nhiệm thay cho em Mọi
quyết định thì rõ ràng là các bạn là
người chịu đâu phải là tôi đúng không
Tôi khuyên các bạn cái gì đó xấu tốt nữa
thì các bạn là người chịu không phải tôi
tôi làm sao tôi biết được đấy nên là
gọi nhỉ Nó là nào giống như kiểu cuốn se
HP ấy đấy các bạn đọc mấy cái đấy trên
mạng có nhan nhản hay là nghe lời khuyên
các thứ mọi người khác cũng là nhan nhản
nhưng mà không chưa chắc là áp dụng đúng
vào cái trường hợp của bạn các bạn phải
tự mình đặt mình xem là mình phù hợp vào
cái gì Vân vân vân Còn nếu mà chính mình
còn chưa hiểu được mình ấy thì mình phải
dành thời gian ra để cố hiểu mình và
bằng một cách là có thể là
thiền à hay là kiểu kiểu dành thời gian
ra nh ngồi suy nghĩ à Còn không thì làm
hành động được Nghĩa đại khái đấy thử
công việc này công việc kia xem công
việc nào phù hợp mình Vân Vân làm đủ mọi
cách để mà hiểu được bản thân mình hiểu
bản thân mình càng sớm mình sẽ càng biết
được là mình cần phải làm gì tiếp theo
Và nếu mà chưa biết cách làm một cách
đúng đắn thì hỏi người khác Lúc đấy thì
người khác sẽ dễ trả lời cho bạn hơn còn
thực sự là bây giờ giống như là bạn hỏi
tôi là em nên nên kiếm người yêu như thế
nào thì thực ra anh chỉ chia sẻ được góc
Anh thích người yêu như nào Chứ làm sao
đôi biết được là em hợp với người như
thế nào đúng không
bại cả em sẽ
chỉ chỉ được cho là thất bại khi em tự
nhận nó thất thất bại và em bỏ cuộc Còn
không thì nó chỉ là một cái cứ tro một
cái vấp ngã hay một cái gì đó trước khi
em ổn hơn luôn mà giống như Gần đây tôi
tôi chẳng có thất bại gì mấy tôi cảm
thấy đánh đã thế tôi có rất nhiều vấp
ngã nhưng mà tôi cảm thấy tôi không thất
bại đì mấy nhưng mà Gần đây tôi đang bị
trùng xuống này đang bị trầm xuống này
thế Tôi nghĩ là cái nút trầm này nó cũng
quan trọng để cho những cái nốt thăng
của tôi sau sau này ngay sau này sẽ nổi
bật hơn thế thôi tôi Tôi nghĩ là cuộc
sống phải có thăng trầm không phải lúc
nào mình cũng phất được làm sao mình
phất mãi được có lúc mình sẽ phải mình
sẽ bị phải lùi lại mình sẽ bị lỡ nhịt
đấy Không sao Thế mới tạo nên đ bản nhạc
đúng không ạ Chứ cứ lên mãi là ta lên
được mãi đúng không sẽ có lúc xuống thôi
không vấn đề gì cả đâu quan trọng là sau
đó thì mình phải lên xuống rồi mình mới
lên xuống xuống nữa thì nó bản nhạc này
cũng chán đúng không đấy thế tôi không
vấn đề gì
discord nhá lên kèo cà phê giống như hôm
nay vài anh em lên kèo này thì tôi sẽ có
dịp được gặp gỡ mọi người Tôi không ngại
gặp mọi người đâu Tôi không ngại hỗ trợ
mọi người mọi người cứ nhắn tin hoặc là
Xủ đi mọi thứ thì tôi vẫn sẽ sắp xếp
thời gian để kiểu giao lưu xem nào bởi
vì à Tôi hỗ trợ các bạn nhưng thực cá
các bạn hỗ trợ tôi nhiều mà Thứ nhất là
về mặt tinh thần thứ hai
là kiểu các bạn có rất nhiều câu chuyện
để mà tôi có thể học hỏi cũng như là con
người các bạn có thứ vế sao chúng ta có
thể còn nhờ vả nhau các thứ các thứ bạn
Bạn nhờ tôi về khoản kiến thức của tôi
tôi về sau có thể nhờ bạn về khoản kiến
thức hay là kiểu rất nhiều cái của bạn
không vấn đề gì cả Tôi không nhờ bạn
chúng ta không nên gọi nhỉ trao đổi tiền
n là được vì tôi không có tiền đâu
Ờ đấy Hôm nay
tôi anh nghĩ
Cái gì n ấy lại cũng kiểu tương đối mới
còn đây À đấy Bạn trả đời
rồi Tiếp theo tôi để nói nốt cái chủ đề
này nếu mà các bạn không hỏi nữa thì
mình sẽ tạm nghỉ Hôm nay Ủa hôm nay nói
chuyện cũng bay cuốn phết được một tiếng
40 phút rồi đấy nó là
Hôm nay tôi tự nhiên kiểu nghĩ lại và
tôi suy nghĩ thôi đó
là
à thứ nhất vừa nãy tôi có nói về cái
tính cách đó là mình đang bị kiểu tôi
thực ra là con người cũng hơi bị ảnh
hưởng bởi cảm xúc nghĩa là là mình có
nhiều lúc mình rất là bay kiểu có cảm
xúc kiểu có hứng ấy mình làm việc mọi
thứ rất là bay rất là kiểu
Ờ làm kiểu đ tỉnh táo Minh Mẫn xong rồi
làm mọi thứ cuốn nhiệt tỉ nhưng có những
lúc nó kiểu dạng là mình bị trầm xuống x
bị ảnh hưởng rất nhiều cái
tôi mua con này để mà chống ồn ở công
công ty vì ở công ty tôi có một
bạn theo đồng nghiệp tôi bảo là như cái
loa
kéo tôi thường hay không thích kiểu nó
Ờ không thích nói xấu người khác không
thích đặc biệt nói xấu sau lưng các thứ
không nên bạn ấy khá là kiểu vô duyên có
vô duyên đúng nghĩa bởi vì tôi vẫn nhớ
là ngoài việc tôi góp
ý góp ý riêng kiểu nhắn tin riêng mà nó
phải mọi thứ lịch sự góp ý thẳng mặt
trước mặt mọi người có và có lần là tôi
đỉnh điểm nhất là là lúc mà Sếp tôi ngồi
đấy ngồi ngay cạnh tôi đang ngồi làm
việc thì bạn ấy đang nói chuyện rất là
to bạn ấy nói chuyện về công việc thì
không sao vậ đang nói chuyện về cá nhân
cơ kiểu Chắc là bạn này chắc là do môi
trường hay vân vân thôi Có thể bạn ở nhà
không có ai nói chuyện được ạ Giống như
tôi không ai nói chuyện thì tôi cũng bị
nói nhiều khi ra ngoài không vấn đề gì
cả như Quan trọng là đấy trong giờ làm
việc thì mình không nên nói to chuyện
riêng riêng tư cá nhân đúng không thì
khi mà tôi nhắn tin inbox riêng nhá nhở
bạn đấy có xếp ở đây đấy đấy Nói bé thôi
có thử thử thì B còn đứng dậy nói với
tôi là thì sao đấy là một trong những
cái kiểu không thể chấp nhận được theo
tôi là kiểu đến gión nước làm chăn Ly là
tôi không thể chấp nhận được với cái
thái độ làm việc mọi thứ như thế đấy một
thái độ không hề chuyên nghiệp không hề
tôn trọng cái khác đấy nế mà muỗi Khi mà
mình không người ta không tôn trọng Ngô
trường mà không tr trọng mình thì mình
không tôn trọng người ta đúng không ạ
Đấy nên là tôi cũng muốn nói ra ở đây
mấy ông tôi biết được cái tôi cũng nói
nhiều tôi cũng nói to N là khi mà tôi
kiểu vô tình thôi mình vô tình thôi khi
bị góp ý là mình phải B rút K nghiệm và
và phải xin lỗi đã và thấy mình làm sai
đúng không các bạn ở đây không biết có
bạn là như thế không phải gọi nhở tính
tôi là không thích làm ảnh hưởng người
khác mà nên là không nên như thế có biện
pháp gì không á tôi tôi nhắn hẳn cho bạn
à Công ty tôi nói chung là mọi thứ kiểu
gọi là gì
à Dân chủ à đấy Kiểu thế công ty tôi
kiểu dân chủ đó là kiểu sẽ
có form Ẩn Danh Thế gọi ẩn danh thật ra
mình có thể để thông tin cá nhân và tôi
để thông tin cá nhân tôi thật đấy thấy
không ẩn danh lắm là kiểu nói là kiểu
à kiểu môi trường các thứ thứ thế Ồ nào
các thứ thứ thế thế nên là gần đây tôi đ
chuyển theo công ty tôi bây giờ đang có
hai dự án n cũng hai văn phòng nên là
tôi đ chuyển ra cái dự án à cả dự án tôi
được chuyển sang phòng khác không ngồi
cùng cái bên kia nữa đấy TH khá hay nĩa
là đại khái tôi mua cái tai nghe này để
chống ổn để chống cái kia
thì con Sony lúc nào cũng được cho là
một trong những cái chống ngôn tốt nhưng
nó cũng có cái đó là nó vừa tính năng
vừa là nhược điểm đối với tôi tính năng
là gì Nghĩa là nó cố tình không chống
ngồn âm thanh người nói lắm Bởi vì nó cố
nhận dạng nó để mà mình có thể nghe được
khác nói để vô tình mình sẽ nghe được
người khác kiểu người ta muốn bắt chuyện
mình ấy thì mình nghe được như nhược
điểm như thế là không chống ngôn được
cái loa kéo kia nên thành ra là kìu hơi
khó chịu đấy có thể chống hồn được khá
nhiều thứ còn cái đấy Không đúng rồi đấy
nó còn kiểu nhạy cho cái tiếng tiếng
người nói mà Cáu
là kiểu tôi phủ phủ định cái tính năng
ấy được rõ ràng nhiều lúc kiểu Tôi đang
mạ Tôi đang nghe các th thứ xếp quay ra
bắt bắt chuyện nói thì tôi còn biết được
Anh ấy đang nói giở gì xong rồi mình chỉ
cần giữ như này thì coi như là sẽ nghe
được hoàn toàn người ta nói một cách tạm
thời hoặc là mình bỏ tay nghe ra Thôi
vân vân đấy không bị gián đoạn
lắm Nhưng mà nếu mà Sony mà có tích hợp
thêm cái kiểu là tắt nhận diện Âm thanh
con người hoàn và có khi tôi sẽ tắt Nếu
ở trên văn phòng còn ở ngoài đường thì
mình không nên tắt kiểu vân vân Nói
chung là may bây gi không ngồi làm việc
cùng không sao nhưng mà bạn phải hiểu là
kiểu đấy phải mua hm Tại nghe như thế
bạn phải biết là nó nghiêm trọng như nào
rồi Tại khái là tôi mua hai con luôn ấy
một con
là một con là kiểu tai nghe gắn tai để
mà tôi có đeo tay nghe khi đi được
Nói chung là tôi tấm gương xấu đừng có
học theo
nhá và hai là cái t n kiểu như để mình
có thể ngồi làm được trên văn phòng thực
ra vì vì Đúng rồi in đấy in mình nghe
đeo in Yêu nhiều không tốt T và nó khó
chịu tai th này nhược điểm Nếu mà nói về
cái này nhược điểm thì tôi thấy là đeo
này lâu nó kiểu Chắc là đầu tôi to không
biết được kiểu
nó hơi bị cấn cấn một tí nên là nghe
được tầm đấy Nãy giờ nghe là đấy tiếng
hơn tiếng rữa rồi Tôi cảm thấy hơi khó
chịu tai một tí đấy khó chịu cả trên này
nữa không biết tôi đeo saiy không gì
Chắc không phải đâu hơi khó chịu ở chỗ
này
ấ không hiểu Nhưng mà thôi vẫn dùng
được à đấy vừa nãy đang nói rồi đó là
cái ha ví dụ là cái
a Tính khí Tôi dùng từ tính khí không
biết đúng không Văn tôi nhều lúc cài Gần
đây tôi bị rối loạn ngôn ngôn ngữ gì đó
nên là văn tôi càng càng cứ sai sai kiểu
gì Nhưng mà đại khái có thể tính khí
à Tính khí của mình sẽ thể hiện qua rất
nhiều hành động của mình đặc biệt là
những hành động rất là nhỏ ví dụ vừa nãy
tôi có để ý nữa ví dụ là tính của tôi là
người Kiểu
nhiệt tình lúc trầm à Chắc thế nẽ là lúc
đi xe T cũng thế nghĩa là chị ạ Không
biết mấy ông đi xem mánh như nào đại
khái gì Tụi đi theo kiểu nó sẽ viết
nhanh đoạn nào có thể nhanh Xong rồi
đoạn đi chậm thì tôi sẽ lại kiểu VT lại
chậm và thường có thể phanh gấp kểu thế
Thực ra ví nhanh đ với tôi Bây giờ tôi
đi tốc độ 20 cây mà nên là thực ra viết
nhanh tôi Thỉnh thoảng lên là 30 thôi
chứ không phải cực kỳ nhanh đâu nhá có
nhiều ông phòng nhanh không nói nhưng mà
Đấy đấy nó thể hiện qua cái tính khí cái
tính cách của mình ở việc đi xe luôn tôi
nghĩa là tôi phải điềm tĩnh lại tôi phải
luôn giữ ổn định luôn bình tĩnh và đương
nhiên là bao gồm cả việc đi xe luôn
nghĩa là mình sẽ chỉ viết và mình giữ
cái tốc độ đây luôn ổn định chứ không
phải lúc nhanh và lúc chậm các thứ thứ
thế như thế cả cả về việc
à cách mình bóp phanh nữa hoặc thậm chí
là cách mình bóp coi nữa đấy đấy à
vân vân Nói chung là mình phải giữ được
cái sự ổn định trong cả việc đi xe dẫn
đến những cái ổn định trong những cái
việc
khác các bạn phải luyện rất nhiều cái
ngay việc là phải ngồi thẳng lưng này
nãy giờ không ngồi thẳng lưng lỗi tôi
tôi sẽ luyện các bạn ngồi thẳng lưng cho
tấm gương
sáng thứ hai
là luyện gì nhở tô nhớ Luyện à đi đi giá
phòng đi mình đi thẳng lưng Không gù này
Ờ đi điềm điềm tĩnh tự tin phong thái
này người ta bảo người mà hay đi nhanh
thì người hay vất vả Đúng không à không
phải hay đi nhanh mà là người đi dáng
vất vả ấy ông ông không tôi chả biết
dùng từ như nào kiểu trông bận rộn ấy
kiểu trông à kiểu cấp gáp ấy nó sẽ vất
vả và trông vẻ bận rội đấy hỏi luyện đi
dáng Sao trông vẻ kho khoan khi có thể
cái chân ông vẫn đi nhanh rồi nhá Tôi có
vẻ luyện được dần cái đấy rồi nghĩa là
thao tác chân ở dưới chân ấy trông vẫn
cực kỳ nhanh luôn tôi đi quen này đi tốc
độ nhanh r mà nhưng mà trên thần thái
mình trông ở trên vẫn điềm tĩnh kiểu
kiểu đi tác phòng kiểu thanh thản ấy đấy
luyện được kiểu đấy tác phong đi đứng
này Đấy Nói chung là m không phải luyện
dần cái thế thậm chí là tôi còn luyện
được Mỗi tội tôi mới luyện được một tay
thôi đó đi không vung
tay rất hạn chế vung tay hoặc là nếu
vung tay thì mình không vông tay cao
vông tay th C Tự nhiên rồi Bây giờ tôi
thực ra bởi vì tôi luyện được cái kiểu
không vông tay Thành ra đi Thành
Đà không có tay tay của tôi hơi bị gượng
cũng hơi Nhược điểu một tí tay bên trái
tôi đi kiu đúng ạ thẳng bởi vì cái đây
Thực ra là tôi luyện cái thói quen này
là do hồi bé là tôi có cái thát lưng
nhưng nó bị dài quá nhưng mà dài như kiu
nửa vờ nên thành ra tay bên trái Tôi sẽ
luôn giữ cái thát lưng đấy nên thành ra
tay trái tôi luôn thẳng đứng Ờ đút túi
Thực ra tôi thường ha Đi đút túi đấy Tôi
cũng không biết khuyên các bạn như nào
Thực ra nó không phải là một cái t Phong
đẹp hay hay
cái góc nhìn tôi thôi tôi bảo rồi đấy là
con người tôi Phong thẳng phong cách
thần thái của tôi đấy nên là tôi đang
nói không phải là các bạn nên nên làm
theo mà đang nói là đấy góc nhìn của tôi
các bạn có thể tham khảo và các bạn sẽ
sửa theo phù hợp với với cách của bạn ví
dụ Giả sử bạn muốn người khác nhìn bạn
là con người như nào Ví dụ là tôi là một
con người Kiểu muốn người khác nhìn vào
tôi kiểu trung trí thức thoải mái thì
tôi sẽ kiểu thể hiện bộc lộ mình kiểu
trí thức thoải mái tức cả cái Phong Thái
thần thái Phả vẫn phải thoải mái đúng
không Đừng có lúc nào Khoanh tay kiểu
này đừng có lúc nào kiểu hai tay cho vào
túi quần nó kiểu trông kiểu mình bị hồi
trước tôi đọc vài cái nghe vài cái đấy
Nó là kiểu làm người khác nhìn thấy mình
có vẻ người mình bị bảo thủ kiểu thu hẹp
bản thân ấy Vân Vân có rất nhiều cái đấy
là một cái động tác kiểu nó kiểu khép
mình lại ấy đấy mình cũng phải sửa lại
mấy cái đấy Nói chung là tôi nghĩ là
không biết là các bạn đã đến tầm tuổi
phải để ý mấy cái điều đấy chưa nhưng mà
nhưng mà nếu để ý sớm thì tốt vì cái đấy
nó cũng cải thiện khá nhiều
đấy đầu tiên là cải thiện về cái tư
tưởng mình đã chắc chắn là mấy cái đấy
không thể một sớm một chiều đúng không ạ
Không thể một sớm một chiều không phải
tôi nói thế xong ủi Hôm nay ông đú kết
được hết Ông áp dụng được hết Ông nhớ
được hết không nhưng mà thay đổi cái
thêm được góp Nhìn này Đấy xong mình sẽ
nghĩ dần với nó xong mình đấy tôi bảo
hôm nay tôi bảo các bạn Lợi khuyên các
bạn phải luôn có cái app này ghi đi chố
lại các bạn nhớ là cái gì Các bạn phải
đừng có cậy mình nhớ được tốt chẳng ai
chí nhớ tốt đến thế mình luôn ghi lại
mình thấy nốt lại luôn ghi chú lại tất
cả những cái thứ mình cần làm mình đặc
biệt là mấy cái đấy là mấy cái thói quen
cần làm hàng ngày luôn mình sẽ phải cần
sửa hàng ngày mình cần chình lại hàng
ngày ngi thẳng lưng hay làm mọi thứ đấy
nói chuyện với sếp nên nhìn thẳng mắt
Sếp không Thực ra là giao tiếp bằng ánh
mắt nó quan trọng nhưng mà tôi lại không
giỏi về cái việc giao tiếp ở mắt không
quen nhìn thẳng chằm chằm vào ai đó nên
tôi không biết nhận xét mấy ông như thế
nào mắt tôi còn gọi nhìn chăm chú ai đó
chắc là tôi nghĩ là mắt tôi bị trợn lên
mất n là tôi cũng cũng không nhìn thẳng
cụ thể nhưng mà tôi cũng tôi cũng kiểu
cũng đang phải học cách lắng nghe mà học
cách nói chuyện mà nên là tôi tôi cũng
luyện dần là nhìn vào cái góc khác cũng
được không cần nhìn thẳng mặt chỉ cần
thức ra mấu chốt ở đây vẫn là làm sao
người ta biết được là mình đang chăm chú
lắng nghe và đang tập trung vào câu
chuyện này là được mà đúng không Đấy
mình làm sao cho thể hiện được tất cả
những điều đấy được đâu cần nhất thết
Nếu mà em bị ngại nhìn vào mắt người ta
thì em cần gì em phải cố Cố nhìn vào bởi
vì em cố nhìn vào mắt em kiểu Dương
Dương lên người ta còn sợ em hơn đúng
không ạ Đấy mắt em phải đẹp rồi mắt em
phải cái gì đó kiểu Ánh mắt đưa tình
quyến rũ được thì em mới cố nhìn và mắt
người ta người ta mới có cảm tình chứ
mắt em kiểu trận ngược nhìn
người nó lại thành điểm trừ đúng không
đấy thì nói chung là mấy ông phải biết
được thế mạnh ưu và nhược của mình là gì
nếu mình cảm thấy mình không phù hợp thì
mình đừng có cố gồng vào đúng
không Đừng có cố gồng vào mấy cái điều
đấy đấy Hôm nay tôi có bạn nói tôi kiểu
thế đó là các
bạn cũng phải kiểu đang luyện để ngồi
thẳng lưng các thứ các thứ tôi bảo là
nhiều lúc tôi thả lỏng tôi không ngồi
thẳng lưng đâu vì rõ ràng là vì rõ ràng
là tôi đang không quen điều đấy tự nhiên
bây giờ tôi cứ cố ng thẳng tôi là tôi
đang phải gồng và tôi gồng thế người
khác sẽ cảm thấy là cũng không thoải mái
không tự nhiên đấy Tôi đang Tôi đang
muốn là mang cái môi cái không khí tự
nhiên thoải mái nhất cho người xung
quanh người đối diện tôi phải làm mọi
thứ tôi thoải mái đã đúng không ạ thì
người xung quanh sẽ thấy à Ông này đang
rất là thân thiện kiểu thoải mái các thử
các thứ thì người ta sẽ dễ mở lòng hơn
với mình đúng không ạ không sao Còn
những cái kia là mình nên luyện ở nhà
mình luyện cá nhân mình mình sửa dần còn
khi ra ngoài thì mình vào tù môi trường
mình mới nên kiểu thích nghi sao phù hợp
không nên dập khuôn quá đúng không ạ nên
thoải mái đấy cá thử th Nãy giờ tôi ngồi
nói chuyện thoải mái Nhưng mà tôi mới
nhớ ra tôi cần phải sửa lưng n tôi sẽ
ngồi thẳng lưng một tí đây Ừ đúng rồi
Bây giờ tôi sẽ phải thay đổi thói quen
bằng cái là tôi sẽ phải nâng cái
màn hình cao lên một tí này ơ cái này
không nghiêng được không được cao lên
một tí này
Đấy ma cũ mà thường coi thường ma mới
á
tôi từng gặp một người như thế ở trong
công ty chứ còn cả công ty nói nói chung
và cả là môi trường từng gặp th C tội
mới tham gia mỗi ba công ty không đủ
nhiều để đánh ra lắm Tôi may mà tôi ciểu
tính Tội thân thiện kiểu cố hoa đồng với
mọi người và mọi người cũng thấy kiểu
mình làm được việc và mình kiểu cũng sẵn
sàng hỗ trợ người ta nên là người ta
cũng thoải mái mình lắm cũng không không
gây áp lực khó khăn ch mình
tạo ngừng đã kiểu nói Khảm rọng rồi chắc
là còn các bạn có gì cứ hỏi thì à Một là
điền form câu hỏi tôi thấy ở đây cũng
chưa thấy điền cái gì cả hai là hai nhắn
tin trong server để tôi trả lời dần nhá
Đúng rồi Nếu mà hỏi về câu laptop thì cứ
vừa tối tiền là mua không cần phải nghĩ
đến khó
xa hoặc là kiếm một cái laptop cũ để đổ
học và đổ đến thời gian đi thực tập Còn
khi mà thực tập xong thì cô kiếm Hà con
laptop từ tế mới nếu mà giả sử là tiền
của em bây giờ chỉ giấy hạn dưới 10
triệu mắt em bị nhìn lệch một bên các
thứ
thứ mắt anh cũng bị lệch đấy mắt anh
không phải để anh một phần là do bệnh
thì phải nên là mắt cũng bị lệch l tí
nên là anh cũng có tự ti về mắt nhưng mà
anh nghĩ là
không đấy thì thực ra tôi tự ti tôi
nhiều cái tôi khẳng định tôi phải đẹp
trai các thứ thứ Thế Thành là mình sẽ
phải tạo ấn tượng cho người khác bằng
cái khác ví dụ đôi khi là tôi không Nhớ
tôi có nút ruồi môi này chẳng hạn người
khác có thể để ý như về sau mấy ông sẽ
thấy mấy ông sẽ chẳng để ý tôi bởi mấy
cái đấy mấy ông sẽ để ý tôi bằng cái
khác đúng không cái kia chỉ ấn tượng đầu
một tí thôi không sao cả mình sẽ làm nổi
bật BN thân mình bằng những cái mà mình
thực sự muốn người ta nhìn vào muốn
người ta đỉ được thế rất là
tốt Ok nhỉ tạm nghỉ th nhỉ Chào mấy ông
nhá B nói chuyện hô n rất vui và cảm
động rất súc động ạ Xin cảm ơn ạ Bye bye